[Musique]
Hubert Vidride, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Vous voulez que je régume ma ma vie en
une minute ?
Vous vous présentez ? Ben voilà, je suis
né en 1947
et j'ai été j'ai fait plein de choses
dans ma vie variée. L'élément le plus
connu, c'est que j'ai été pendant 19 ans
au cœur du pouvoir.
Pas dans la politique, dans le cœur du
pouvoir. 14 années que François Mitrand
du premier au dernier jour comme cancil
diplomatique porte-parole secrétaire
général. Donc, j'ai connu les le pouvoir
de gauche avec tous les premiers
ministres mais les deux cohabitations et
puis 2 ans après, ministre des affaires
étrangère
sous la présidence Jack Chirac sur
proposition de Lionel Jospin qui était
premier ministre pendant 5 ans. Donc 14
+ 5 19 donc 19 années dans le cœur du
pouvoir ce qui encore une fois ça n'a
rien à voir avec une une carrière
politique. Ça c'est le point important.
En fait, j'ai fait plein de choses avant
et plein de choses après.
Et après euh
donc à la fin du gouvernement Joseph en
2002 2003
pendant quelques années, plutôt quelques
mois, on va dire pendant quelques mois,
je me suis posé la question de m'engager
moi-même dans la compétition politique.
J'ai réfléchi, beaucoup de gens m'y
encouragé
et finalement j'ai conclu que non pour
36 raisons
personnelles, privé, familial mais aussi
intellectuel mais aussi politique mais
aussi lié à ce que j'avais vu de
l'évolution de ce qu'est le pouvoir et
la les conditions de de vie, de travail
et de décision des gens qui sont au
pouvoir dans les démocraties modernes.
Enfin bref, j'ai fait un autre choix. Je
suis pas resté non plus au Conseil
d'État et j'ai décidé à ce moment-là de
pour assurer mon autonomie, mon
indépendance de créer une société de
conseils
sur la géopolitique et je travaille pour
de grandes entreprises françaises, de
grandes ou des moyennes qui ont besoin
d'analyser le contexte et le risque mais
aussi peut-être les opportunités en
géopolitique. C'est ce qui m'a toujours
passionné puisque avant d'être mini,
j'ai beaucoup voyagé, j'ai même été
routard à un moment donné, voyez. En
Afghanistan,
par exemple, j'étais avec des copains,
on avait acheté euh un groupe de 12, on
avait acheté trois vieilles bagnoles et
on est parti en Afganistan en voiture
sur la route de ce livre magnifique
l'usage du monde mais en fait qu'on a de
Nicolas Vanier mais que j'ai découvert
après en fait c'était le livre de Kessel
les cavaliers qui avaient donné cette
idée. Enfin bref, donc depuis depuis
2003, j'ai une société, ça me prend
quand même la moitié de mon temps. C'est
pas du dilettantisme, faut analyser des
situations, les risques chiffres
d'affaires de 1,3 million d'euros.
Oui, c'est public en effet. Et l'autre
moitié de montant, c'est plein d'autres
choses. Je prévide les rencontres
photographiques d'Arl.
D'ailleurs, je aujourd'hui même le le
bureau donc moi en tant que président
mais la vice-présidente ont été
reconduit ce matin. C'était sympathique.
Et puis je préside de la fondation
Mitteran depuis également longtemps.
C'est pas un organe politique, il s'agit
pas de s'exprimer sur l'actualité mais
c'est un organe de historique de
mémoire. Enfin, je fais plein de trucs
et puis je fais des livres et puis le le
dernier c'est sur la géopolitique mais
j'en ai fait d'autres mais je fais plein
de choses et puis c'est la vie en
général. Donc le choix que j'ai fait le
choix que j'ai fait en 2002 2003 c'est
un choix de liberté. En fait
ça tombe bien aujourd'hui on va parler
de géopolitique. Est-ce qu'un homme
comme vous peut parler maintenant ?
Ah mais j'attendais avant aussi hein.
J'ai jamais pratiqué la langue de bois.
La langue de bois c'est important parce
que ça permet de de calmer les conflits.
Ça permet de pas être agressif
inutilement. C'est un langage codé en
fait.
Et dans la diplomatie, il faut pas jeter
de l'huile sur le feu. Il faut défendre
des intérêts parfois vigoureusement,
prendre des positions très nettes à
certains moments, mais il faut pas dire
ce qui vous passe par la tête. Donc
c'est un langage de respect, de
responsabilité mais évidemment un peu
verrouillé. Mais quand on regarde quand
on regarde les textes de l'époque où
j'étais ministre,
il y a j'espère enf je crois qu'il y a
pas tellement de de phrases crues pour
ne rien dire hein.
Est-ce que vous m'autor
Mais on est encore plus libre après
évidemment. Est-ce que vous m'autorisez
à à qualifier le langage diplomatique du
21e siècle
comme un langage d'hypocrite ou de si
vous me permettez l'expression de faux
cul ?
Mais c'est inexact parce que ce que vous
avez dit c'est l'ensemble du langage en
société.
Voyez, vous passez votre temps à dire à
des gens dont vous avez rien à
comment ça va cher ami tout ça en fait
vous en figez mais c'est pas mal de dire
ça.
Donc toute la journée pour rendre la vie
sociale un peu fluide et pas agressive,
on emploie des formules qui sont des de
la langue de bois mais privée à titre
personnel ou familial ou dans un couple.
Voyez
donc c'est c'est pas spécial Non. Le
problème de la la langue de voix
diplomatique c'est une langue de
responsable. Ils savent que les mots
peuvent tuer en fait peuvent déclencher
des choses. Donc quand il faut se battre
avec des mots ou autrement, ils le font.
Mais il s'agit pas de de céder à ses
sentiments, ses impulsions. Voyez, c'est
le contraire exact de le l'ambiance
d'une culture où on met avant la disons
le ressenti, avant le raisonnement.
C'est pas ça. Non, les langues de bois
des différents métiers les langues de
bois des médecins des juristes, c'est
plutôt respectable sauf si on est
complètement enfermé dedans. Moi, j'en
défends l'usage, un usage responsable
mais il faut être à un moment donné
capable de transgresser par rapport à
ça. De toute façon, ça me caractérise
pas du tout, hein. Si si je vous dis
dans aucune de mes incarnations
si je vous dis la politique, du moins la
guerre c'est le prolongement de la
politique. Ça vous fait penser à quoi ?
à une autre époque.
Oui, c'est vrai. Mais pendant très
longtemps, jusqu'à ce qu'on arrive à
notre époque où quand même tout le monde
est interdépendant, le nombre de guerres
contrairement les gens a beaucoup
diminué en fait. Donc donc c'est pas
l'aboutissement logique, mais il y a eu
quelques siècles en Europe et ailleurs
hein où il y avait la politique, le
rapport de force, la négociation
et à certains moment
qui était considérée comme un un moyen
presque normal de régler les conflits.
C'était des professionnels qui se
battaient. Ça n'a rien à voir avec les
les guerres du 20e siècle, ni avec
l'enroulement massif, encore moins que
les victimes civiles. Bon, donc c'est
vrai qu'il y a eu des dirigeants, que ce
soit des rois, des papes ou des
dictateurs ou des tyrans, qui utilisent
la guerre à certains moments. Et
d'ailleurs quand on se dit mais comment
est-ce que les dirigeants en Europe
n'ont pas compris avant 1914
qu'ils allaient à la guerre mondiale
parce que il y en avait jamais eu.
C'était impensable une guerre mondiale.
Donc il pensaiit régler des problèmes
réels ou inventés peu importe par
différents moyens de négociation de par
éventuellement par une guerre limitée
assez commode pour trancher un sujet.
Donc il voyait pas le qu'on était en
train de passer avec l'industrialisation
dans un autre monde. Mais c'est plus le
cas aujourd'hui. Regardez entre même pas
uniquement les Européens, c'est un peu
particulier mais même dans les relations
tendues
Europe Europe Chine ou plutôt Europe
Russie on va dire États-Unis Chine, on
peut imaginer des scénarios qui peuvent
conduire peut-être peut-être à des
vraies guerres mais même là c'est pas
évident voyez. Alors, il y a d'autres
guerres que la guerre hein. Il y a la
guerre
les guerres secrètes.
Alors bon, c'est il y a les choses
secrètes, mais les choses secrètes,
c'est pas des guerres si c'est secret,
c'est pas des vraies guerres, c'est la
préparation ou c'est une façon de les
éviter. Évidemment, il y a des
affrontements énormes sur le terrain
économique, sur le terrain
technologique, sur le terrain numérique,
sur avec tous les terrains. Mais c'est
pas la guerre au sens de 141.
Le mot est impropre. C'est la
compétition, c'est le conflit. Voyez,
c'est des choses comme ça, mais c'est
pas la guerre au sens massif.
cette violence de basse intensité,
ce climat de guerre froide qu'on est en
train de reconnaître ou se reprofiler
devant nous, la France se positionne
comment ? La France du 21e siècle, la
France de Macron ? Comment vous évaluez
les chances de la France pour les 5
prochaines années ?
Alors, attendez, il y a plusieurs
questions parce que guerre froide ou
pas, la France et cetera. D'abord la
guerre froide, rappelons à nos amis qui
nous écoutent que c'est la
caractéristique de l'affrontement entre
les États-Unis et l'URS pendant
plusieurs dizaines d'années de après la
2e guerre mondiale jusqu'à
l'effondrement de l'URS. La date
importante c'est pas la chute du mur,
c'est la fin de l'URS 2 ans après. Donc
c'était une guerre froide. Froide ? Elle
est restée froide, elle est pas devenue
chaude. C'est ça qui est important. On
n'est pas passé loin quand même.
Bah oui, mais euh c'est pas devenu une
guerre à cause de la dissuion nucléaire.
Beaucoup de gens contestent ça pour
différentes raisons, mais non, moi je
crois que c'est la dissuision nucléaire
qui a empêché même si elle était on n
pas besoin de d'autant de missiles et
d'autant de bombes pour ça hein. Ça peut
être beaucoup plus simple et beaucoup
plus modeste. En tout cas, la guerre est
restée froide heureusement. Et la fin de
l'URSE qui était très crainte par
beaucoup de gens qui pensaient qu'il y
aurait autour de l'Allemagne une guerre
en Europe. Il y a pas eu de guerre
finalement. Bon, alors est-ce que
maintenant on entre dans des nouvelles
guerres froides ? Oui, on peut le dire
quand même hein, entre l'Occident et la
Russie. C'estàd curieux parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'on a encore plus peur de
Poutine que de l'URS avant. Al l'URS
était beaucoup plus puissante, beaucoup
plus dangereuse, beaucoup plus
agressive. Elle sinait plus de gens.
Enfin bon, ça c'est le sujet Russie. et
on est dans un début de guerre froide
États-Unis, Chine. Espérons qu'elle va
rester froide et qu'il y aura pas par
exemple à propos de Taïwan, voyez, un
enchaînement qui conduirait un
affrontement un jour. Bon, quant à la
France, la France c'est il y a des
batailles pour la la classifier. Moi,
j'avais inventé il y a longtemps quand
j'étais au Quédor l'expression puissance
moyenne d'influence mondiale.
Alors, on n'est pas la grande puissance
sur États-Unis, on n'est pas la Chine
d'aujourd'hui.
Et puissance moyenne, quand Giscar avait
dit ça il y a longtemps, il avait raison
d'ailleurs. Il y a eu un toolé. Comment
puissance moyenne, la France qui est un
pays tellement extraordinaire, il y a
beaucoup de réactions nég il avait
raison. Pourquoi ? Parce que dans les
200 pays à peu près des Nations- Unies,
il y a même pas 20 puissances,
il y a une quinzaine de puissances.
Donc les puissances établies avant et
les puissances montantes. Si la France
qui fait 65 millions d'habitants, la
superficie que l'on connaît, qui est une
puissance clé dans l'histoire du monde
depuis plusieurs siècles, l'est encore
aujourd'hui. Le simple fait d'être dans
les puissances, c'est devrait réjouir
les Français.
Mais en ils sont pessimistes sur leur
pays, parmi les plus pessimistes au
monde sur l'avenir de leur propre pays.
Bon, donc c'est une puissance moyenne
d'influence mondiale qui s'est effondré
en 40. Le fait majeur, le plus tragique
de l'histoire de France, pire que la
guerre de 100 ans, c'est l'effondrement
de juin 40. Et après quoi, la France
avait disparu aux yeux de Staline, aux
yeux de Roosevelt et cetera et de Gaul à
Londres. Enfin pour les grands
dirigeants, la France était hors jeu
terminé et c'est grâce à Churchill qu'on
était remis dans le jeu après. Bon alors
de Gaul a a réinventé la chose et puis
le mythe la l'idée, l'ambition. Beaucoup
de gens pensaient que la gauche balérait
ça mais quand Mant est arrivé, il a
endossé le gaisme, il l'a transformé
avec plus d'Europe et cetera. Il y a une
longue période où on se dit on est quand
même revenu à notre niveau. Mais quand
la guerre froide s'est terminée, donc
fin de l'URS,
la France qui avait une position assez
confortable, intelligemment utilisée
par les présidents que j'ai cité puis
également Pompidou, Giscar et cetera et
Cherak après un peu donc la France qui
était un allié de l'Occident mais quand
même autonome à l'est au sud.
La France a perdu cette situation assez
commode et qu'on entre dans une longue
période dans laquelle on est toujours où
tous les président successif
essaie de repositionner la France dans
un environnement mondial qui change tout
le temps, qui est complètement instable.
C'est plus si net que ça mais ils ont la
même idée. Il faut que la que ce soit la
droite ou la gauche ou autre chose,
c'est la même idée. Il faut que la
France reste maîtresse de ces décisions
quand même. Vous voyez ? souveraine.
Alors souveraine, on peut pas l'être
complètement. On est dans un monde
totalement interdépendant.
Donc on va pas être totalement
souverain. En tout cas, on peut pas être
souverain au change d'autonomie
autarchique. Ça c'est impossible.
Aucun pays dans le monde ne peut l'être
aujourd'hui. Tout le monde dépend de
tout le monde, voyez. Et même la Chine
dépend sur certains points. Il y a
versement, Taïwan, tout ça.
Ce qui est souhaitable aujourd'hui,
c'est comme souveraineté, faut le
prendre au sens un peu schématique, un
peu simplifié. On veut rester maître de
notre destin. On veut pas dépendre que
des autres. Alors dans l'Europe
d'aujourd'hui parce que l'Europe a été
très très naïf quand même pendant des
décennies un peu niais, un peu niggaude.
Ben on dépend d'un peu tout le monde
hein.
Comment ça se fait d'ailleurs qu'elle
était aussi nigde ?
Vous savez après la deuxème guerre
mondiale
les Européens les Américains il rentré
chez eux.
Les européens lois ont été terrorisés
par Staline
qui n'appliquaient pas les promesses
faites à Yalta. S'il faisait l'inverse,
il mettait la main sur l'Europe de
l'Est. Ils ont supplié les Américains de
revenir.
Les Américains voulaient pas. Le Sénat
ne voulait pas. Il voulait pas charger
d'une alliance militaire. Le président
Truman trop oublié. Je consacre
d'ailleurs une entrée dans mon
dictionnaire de géopolitique à Truman a
dit non, on revient parce que c'est
l'intérêt vital des États-Unis que
l'Europe de l'Ouest reste dans cette
orbe. Ils sont revenus. À partir de là,
tous les Européens
chauffent la Grande-Bretagne et la
France pour des raisons coloniales au
début pour d'autres raisons après. On
dit bon, on s'en remet aux États-Unis,
on n'est plus capable, il faut pas parce
que patrie nation nationalisme égale
guerre mondiale là. Donc les Européens
depuis lors depuis des décennies depuis
des décennies vivent dans une bulle
protégé par les l'alliance américaine
même s'il l'oublie de temps en temps en
disant on va faire le paradis sur terre
en fait sur le plan économique social
maintenant
c'est pas une douce musique ça pour nous
vassaliser
non mais Ah non non non c'est pas pour
c'est pas pour ça non c'est nous c'est
nous les Européens évidemment ça arrange
ça arrange le Pentagone et les
Américains mais c'était pas organisé
dans ce but.
Quel regard vous portez sur le
l'Amérique du Pentagone, l'Amérique de
la NSA, l'Amérique qui a des assassins
qui se baladent un peu partout,
l'Amérique qui a un programme secret
avec 60000 contractuels
déployés pour faire de l'astroturfing
sur les réseaux sociaux pour changer
l'opinion publique.
Ça c'est les puissances, on parlait de
l'Amérique là.
Des États-Unis ? Oui.
Oui, mais on peut le dire de la Russie
aussi hein,
avec un programme aussi conséquent. Oui,
bien sûr. Oui, enfin ils ont moins de
moyens quand
ils ont moins de moyens.
Na, c'est des banalités sur les
puissances.
Quand vous avez la NSA
qui met nos nos présidents
sur écoute, quand elle écoute Angué la
Merkel, quand elle récupère l'eau des
toilettes de Pompidou, quand elle c'est
vieux tout ça,
mais ça continue et ça ne fait que
monter en puissance. Quand les
États-Unis,
les États-Unis sont la puissance
dominante, j'aais ça moi il y a
longtemps l'hyperpuissance.
Raymond Aron, on disait ça aussi.
Rond Aron avant même que je sois vrai
parce que l'hyperpuissance américaine,
c'est plutôt après la fin de l'URS.
C'est une puissance dominante. Il faut
quand même mieux que ce soit les
Américains qui clairent qui gagnent la
guerre. Il vaut mieux que ce soit les
Américains plutôt que les le communisme
soviétique et gagner. Bon après, il y a
des phénomènes de puissance. Bon, on
peut s'énerver contre, mais qu'est-ce
qui empêchait les Européens pendant ces
longues décennies de s'organiser par
eux-mêmes, de d'avoir des programmes
technologiques plus avancés, de d'être
en avant des autres, que ce soit pas les
gafans en Californie mais en Europe ?
Qu'est-ce qui ont pêché ça ? Donc ce que
vous me décrivez, c'est évident, c'est
des abus de la puissance qui sont
condamnables, qui sont qui sont pas
acceptables, qui sont lié à des bons
d'ailleurs technologiques gigantesques.
Il y a d'ailleurs plein de
mathématiciens français en Californie.
Pourquoi ils sont en Californie et pas
chez nous ? Voyez donc c'est des choses
c'est des choses disons qui sont
déplorables mais il faut s'en prendre à
nous. Et comme je le rappelais
historiquement après la guerre, ce sont
les Européens qui ont supplié les
Américains de revenir. C'est pas un
impérialisme américain tel qu'il est
descrit de façon de façon simple. He
plus complè Donc ça a créé à la longue,
c'est ça le problème. Ça a créé une
sorte de d'habitude mentale des
Européens. Et moi, j'ai souvent comparé
les Européens.
C'est une ironie gentille, des bisous
nours. Les bisouours dans le monde de
Jurassic Park.
Et il y a le un prison Stein meilleur en
Allemagne a une formule que j'adore. Il
dit "Attention, nous sommes des
herbivores géopolitique
dans un monde de carnivore
géopolitique."
Donc la question, on comprend très bien
le fil historique. C'est pas la peine de
s'énerver contre les Américains ou
contre qui que je sais ou la NSA et
compag il faut s'en prendre à soi-même.
Oui. Non, il faut dire si nous voulons
dépasser cette situation,
c'est pas trop tard.
Non, c'est jamais trop tard. Pourquoi
c'est jamais trop tard ? D'ailleurs les
Américains l'inertie technologique qu'on
a pris.
Oui, mais après il y aura autre chose
après la 5G, il y aura on va inventer
les batteries de l'avenir, on va
inventer la fusion nucléaire. Bon, il y
a des trucs devant nous en fait mais ce
dont nous parlons, c'est le résultat
de la deuxième guerre mondiale de ces
résultats de ces conséquences.
Donc les Européens sont installés dans
une sorte de vie douillette quoi, sympa,
avec une espèce de fuite en avant
sociétale en oubliant les structures.
C'est quoi cette fuite en avant
sociétale ? parce que les ils oublient
la dimension stratégique
et c'était considéré comme étant acquis.
Et puis d'autre part les politiques de
welfare classique inventé après la
deuxième guerre mondiale grâce à la
croissance plus de croissance de plus en
plus d'impôts et donc de plus en plus de
redistribution sociale. Bon on arrive à
la situation où la France est avec le
Danemark le pays le plus imposé au monde
et avec les transferts sociaux grâce à
la fiscalité elle-même aspytiante la
France est le pays le moins inégalitaire
de le CDE après les transferts sociaux.
Tous les Français pensent l'inverse
hein, même pas les gilets jaunes, tout
le monde. Bon, il y a il y a un problème
de décalage par rapport à la réalité et
de il y a un léger manque de culture
économique par rapport à ça. Mais ça
revient à la même remarque. Si on veut
changer, il faut se remuer de nous quoi.
Faut se réveiller. Faut pas s'en prendre
aux États-Unis devenu un protecteur
abusif. Ça nous concerne nous. Voyez
nous. Et alors à l'époque de Trump, moi
j'ai fait partie des gens. Je crois que
c'est ce que pensait le président Macron
aussi que qui croyait que le la
brutalité de Trump, le fait qu'il soit
inquiétant quoi, qui ne garantis pas la
protection euh ça aurait pu provoquer
des réactions importantes en Europe
constructives. On dis on va se raffirmer
comme un un partenaire solide tout ça.
Tu as pas été on n'est pas encore là
hein. Il y a des signes. Il y a des
signes.
Quel Quel regard vous portez sur
l'affaire Snowden ? L'affaire
Snowden,
le fait que la France n'ait pas accordé
l'asile, la fait que la France ne soit
Non, mais c'est pas une affaire
française, c'est une affaire américaine.
Oui, mais il a demandé l'asile en France
aussi, non ?
Oui.
Le fait que nous ne soyons pas capable
de de protéger Snowdon sur notre propre
territoire.
Attendez, ça se discute ça.
Je vous en prie.
Non, non, mais c'est c'est pas Non, mais
c'est pas faux. Mais euh pourquoi est-ce
qu'il faudrait et moi je le considère
pas comme un héros, hein.
Pourquoi ? Parce que je crois aux
sociétés organisées.
Je suis pas libertaire ni.
Vous êtes socialiste.
Même même dans le monde anarchique, même
dans le monde numérique, je crois qu'il
faut un minimum d'organisation, un
minimum de règles. Il y en a pas assez
dans la mondialisation par exemple et je
suis pas prêt à considérer comme un
héros extraordinaire quelqu'un qui qui
je suis pas pour la transparence
généralisée par exemple.
Pourquoi ?
Ben par exemple, je suis pas pour la
transparence des données médicales par
exemple. Voyez ? Et vous remarquerez que
les médias qui militent pour la
transparence ne disent jamais pourquoi
ils ont décidé le matin de mettre tel
sujet en titre plutôt qu'un autre, de
traiter un sujet ou pas un autre.
Quel regard vous pouvez
et les médias s'appliquent jamais à la
transparence elle-même. Évidemment, il
faut de la transparence. Il faut pas, je
voudrais pas que mes propos soient
caricaturés, mais je suis pas non plus
un un adepte de la transparence
généralisée, de mettre à tous les
systèmes et tous les états. Ceci, c'est
pas ma culture. Je suis pas je suis pas
un californien.
Je suis pas comme les les gars de la
Californie qui imaginent d'acheter une
île au milieu du Pacifique pour se créer
une sorte de territoire totalement
sauvage, indépendant, autonome et qui ne
dépendent plus de personne. Vous
pour la sécession,
notamment pas des gens de Washington qui
pouvrai pour imaginer de démembrer les
gaffins.
Bon, c'est pas ma culture, c'est tout.
J'ai pas fermé à tous ces aspects mais
je viens pas de ça moi.
Donc Snowden, c'est un traître, c'est
pas un traître.
Non mais je pas j'emploie pas des grands
mots.
Vous êtes diplomate ?
Non, je suis psychologue.
C'est rare chez les diplomates.
Je signale que j'ai jamais fait partie
du corps diplomatique. Par les hasards
de la vie. Je suis devenu chef de la
diplomatie en effet mais j'étais pas
membre du corps. J'ai pas mené une
carrière diplomatique. J'ai pas été
ambassadeur dans dans différents
endroit. Donc Snowdon non mais c'est
dommage, il a cru bien faire.
La machine de pouvoir américaine
s'acharne sur lui. C'est quand même une
une puissance hein système américain.
Bon il vaudrait mieux qu'il puisse être
traité équitablement aux États-Unis, ça
serait mieux.
Mais entrer dans un schéma dans lequel
on donne agile à des Américains qui vont
donner agile à je ne sais quel individu
européen, c'est pas
B. C'est de votre époque ça l'affaire
Vladimir Vetrof ?
C'est juste avant.
C'est pas mon époque, c'est l'époque de
Mitteran. Alors, il faut expliquer à nos
téléspectateurs, auditeurs le je sais
pas quoi, quel est le terme d'ailleurs
que vous employez pour les les gens qui
vous suivent ? nos internautes, nos
téléspectateurs, nos auditeurs, nos
followers, nos abonés.
avant l'élection avant l'élection de
Miterran en 81,
il y avait un cadre important des des
services d'espionnage soviétique
et qui est qui connaissait qui avait mis
la main sur l'ensemble du système des
espions soviétiques questionnés la
technologie occidentale et l'URS à la
fin ne survivait que comme ça d'ailleurs
en pompant les trucs et il était
révolté, il trouvait le système
soviétique dangereux pour la paix du
monde. qui voulait euh lutter contre et
il voulait donner donc trahir son pays
en fait. Il voulait donner des
informations secrètes mais pas aux
Américains. Donc par patriotisme russe,
c'était pour lui inacceptable de le
donner aux Américains. Donc il l'a donné
au représentant de la DST française, pas
la DGSE pour différents raisons DST.
C'était avant l'élection.
Il se trouve que c'est Mittérant qui
était élu. Si Giscar avait été réélu,
c'est lui qui aurait bénéficié de cette
de cette opération qui était peut-être
la plus grande opération disons de
révélation de secret soviétique de toute
la guerre froide. Il se trouve que c'est
Mitta élu à une époque où Rean
s'inquiétait énormément d'un
gouvernement socio-communiste à Paris.
Et donc ça fait partie des éléments que
Méan a pu utiliser pour pacifier
sa relation avec tout de suite. Voyez
Farwell
Farwell et le malga était finalement
assassiné hein
parce queoné par les
parce que les services français l'ont
l'ont l'ont abandonné.
Non c'est pas pour ça. Non non non non
non. Il a finalement c'est à cause
d'histoire privée en fait privée qu'il a
attiré l'attention sur lui qui a eu des
ça n'a rien à voir ni avec les Français
ni avec les Américains.
Et moi je m'occupe pas de ça. Quand je
suis arrivé à l'Élysée, j'avais 34 ans.
J'étais un modeste conseiller technique
pour les relations extérieures, donc
conseiller diplomatique. Et c'est au fil
des années que j'ai pris de plus de de
un rôle plus grand quoi dans dans le
système. À l'époque, c'était géré en
direct par le patron de la DST et
François Mitrant, hein.
Le patron.
Quel regard vous portez sur le quai d'Or
quand quand on entend des expressions
comme le dormeur du quai,
la passivité intellectuelle du qu
d'Orset, l'immobilisme du qu d'ors ?
Le les diplomates sont habitués à ça,
vous savez. Il y a des colibés déjà dans
Poust la présentation de NordP fait fait
sourire. Bon, ils sont habitués à ça. Il
se trouve que honnêtement, il y a une
vraie différence entre l'époque d'avant
le téléphone, on va dire d'avant le
télég téléphone et les avions dans
lesquels les rois, les papes, les
empereurs avaient des envoyés, ils ont
inventé la diplomatie, ils ont entend
les ambassadeurs, tout ça, des immunités
pour les protéger. C'était dangereux
hein. Et donc les gens qui étaient
chargés d'une mission de ce genre
avaient une importance géante
géante. Ils allaient, il partaient pour
3 mois, avait une négociation de ceci
cela et il y avait personne pour leur
téléphoner et leur envoyer des
instructions sur SMS toutes les 3
minutes, hein. Donc c'était
extraordinaire. Toute une partie de la
légende de la la diplomatie en Europe,
c'est ça en fait. En Europe et ailleurs,
mais c'était inventé là entre les villes
italiennes au début.
Bon, quand on arrive à l'époque moderne
où d'abord les dirigeants se
rencontrent,
les sommets, ça pas commencé au 20e
siècle, il y en a eu avant, bon même
sous Napoléon 3, mais ça s'est développé
au 20e siècle à cause de l'avion. Puis
avant, il y avait le téléphone. Donc la
marche de manœuvre, la disons le mandat
des émissaires, ambassadeurs, ceci cela,
chargé d'affaires, c'est beaucoup
réduit. C'est resté très intéressant.
C'est resté très très passionnant. C'est
une façon merveilleuse d'être attaché à
son pays, projeté dans le monde. Enfin,
c'est extraordinaire pour les gens qui
aiment l'histoire, la géographie, la
politique, les voyages et cetera. Il y a
il y a il y a pas plus excitant. Mais de
plus en plus, c'est les dirigeants qui
ont absorbé ça. Et aujourd'hui,
d'ailleurs, on voit bien dans les
relations internationales, les ministres
jouent un rôle plus modeste, on va dire.
Alors, moi, j'ai une chance folle, on
est deux dans ce cas, à être ministre
pendant la cohabitation.
Le deuxème, c'était qui ? Alors dans mon
cas, c'était quand j'étais ministre,
c'était entre Jacques Chirac et Lionel
Jospin. Si Lonel Jospin qui m'avait
choisi, je lui en suis éternellement
reconnaissant. C'était sous la
présidence de Chirak. Et donc entre les
deux, connaissant bien les idées des
deux, en fait, j'avais une assez grande
autonomie pour définir la politique.
Donc j'étais chef de la diplomatie en
vrai. Alors d'habitude quand on dit chef
de la diplomatie pour les ministres,
c'est les sous-chefs parce que c'est les
présidents au chancelier et l'autre
personne c'est Alain Jupé dans la
deuxième cohabitation entre François Mit
Édouard Baladur.
Mais sinon, il faut reconnaître que
c'est plus compliqué, c'est plus ingrat
qu'avant. Euh donc les colib euh bon peu
importe. Alors en plus quand vous êtes
un ministre français, vous avez euh les
relations avec le monde entier mais la
il y a la dimension européenne. Les
Européens ils passent leur temps à se
parler tout le temps, tout le temps,
tout le temps, tout le temps. Même dans
sortir quoi ?
C'est les traités, c'est la construction
européenne, c'est le fait que la la
disons le le la décision autonome
complètement autonome de l'Italie ou de
la Chède ou ceci cela est réduite par
les traités. Ils enle devenus de
compétences communautaires européennes.
Vous partagez façon là c'est la partagé
entre le niveau européen et le niveau
national avec le rôle du Parlement.
Donc sur énormément de dans plein plein
de domaines où avant on aurait dit je
décide c'était une bonne ou mauvaise
décision mais je décide voyez le
ministre ou le président là il faut
négocier faut négocier faut discuter.
Bon ça donne le marché commun ça donne
le marché unique ça donne une force
quand même collective ça donne l'euros
ça donne des politiques communes. Que
serait devenu la l'agriculture française
sans la politique agricole commune ? Je
sais pas. Et puis il y a des programmes
nouveaux. regarder tout ce qui est
relancé maintenant avec le avec le Green
Deal de Madame Vlan, la présidente de la
commission
ainsi que dans les le plan de relance.
Mais ça veut dire que la décision de
chaque dirigeant, même le chancelier
allemand, l'Allemagne a le pays le plus
puissant et puis après l'orification le
plus nombreux. Mais même le la
chancelière en ce moment n'a pas une
marge de manœuvre complète. Bon, ça
c'est le prix à payer pour essayer
d'exercer un poids collectif.
Question d'internet,
c'est un choix historique, hein.
Question d'internet. Connaît-il le
scandale Facebook Cambridge Analytica ?
Si oui, que pensent-il ? Qu'en
pensent-il ? Comment stopper l'ingérence
politique et sociale des États ou
entreprises sur internet ? Comment on
fait pour stopper les ingérences sur
notre territoire ? Alors moi je suis pas
très adepte des excité par le scandale.
Donc il faudrait me résumer le scandale
en question.
Cambridge Cambridge euh tiens tu as le
plan à gauche. Euh euh Cambridge
Analytica, c'est
pour résumer trivialement,
j'analyse votre comportement sur
internet
et ensuite je vous envoie de
l'information pour vous faire penser ou
pour vous faire agir dans le sens que je
veux.
Vous avez compris ?
Oui.
C'est vieux comme le monde mais c'est
numérique.
N'importe quelle campagne électorale est
basée là-dessus. N'importe quel bon
vieux politicien à l'ancienne qui sent
l'ambiance des gens, il entre dans un
café, il voit l'ambiance. Voyez, il sait
ce qu'il faut dire. Il faut il se
moquait de ceci mais pas de cela. La
façon de parler tout ça. Bon,
c'est embobiné. Mais alors on est à
l'époque. Oui. Mais
sinon que la manipulation humaine sont
aussi vieux que l'espèce humaine
depuis très très longtemps. Sauf
qu'évidemment dans la dans l'époque
numérique, ça prend des proportions
tellement colossales qu'on a
l'impression que plus rien ne peut y
résister. C'est ça la question. Et
après, c'est qui influence qui quoi ?
Qui interfère sur qui ? Il faut des
règles. Il on c'est évident qu'il va
falloir réguler le monde numérique qui
est un bon partie sauvage pour le
moment. Comme grosso modo, on a quand
même réussi à organiser réguler les
économies nationales. Puis la
globalisation, c'est pas évident. En
fait, c'est une bataille, c'est une
bataille dans la globalisation. Donc je
suis C'est évident que c'est choquant.
Comment on fait pour contrer les
ingérences sur notre territoire à votre
époque ?
Lesquel lesquelles ? Bah toutes les
ingérences extérieures à notre
territoire, les ingérences nuisibles à
l'intégrité des Français.
Oui, mais attendez, ça commence par la
disasion nucléaire, ça. Non, mais
d'accord.
Ça c'est la protection du territoire
national et des intérêts vitaux.
Après, il y a encore une dimension
militaire même s'il est pas nucléaire.
Après vous avez toutes les comme dans
toutes les sociétés organisées, vous
avez des polices, des douanes à la
frontière de Schengen en théorie dans le
système Schengen qui a disjoncté ces
dernières années mais qu'il faut
absolument reconstruire. Et alors après
ça démarre est-ce que c'est des est-ce
que c'est des interférences par la
propagande, par les par les lobby au
moyen des diaspores,
mais à l'époque moderne où tout est
ouvert, tout circule et il y a des
millions d'informations tous les jours
dans 90 % ne valent rien. Bon, ça ça
fait c'est des moyens d'influence. On a
l'impression que c'est entièrement
nouveau tellement la taille est
différente et l'impact est différent.
Mais là aussi tout ça, vous trouvez ça
dans toutes les sociétés humaines
organisées depuis toujours. Toujours, il
y a plein de textes qui ont des textes
de propagande, des tentatives de
manipulation et mais c'est beaucoup plus
massif aujourd'hui.
On voit bien que la mondialisation pour
des raisons technologiques,
le saut numérique, l'invention du
porteconur, enfin tout a fait des bons
d'avant géant géant et que la
l'organisation dans le bon sens du terme
dans le de société organisée et
civilisée et est loin derrière, elle
court derrière. Donc faut retrouver les
niveaux de Oui. Concrètement c'est à
quel niveau ça peut se réglementer. Mais
on a réussi dans le passé, on a bien
réussi à à créer une organisation pour
l'aviation civile. On a réussi à disons
réguler le trafic téléphonique, le
télégraphe, la négociation sur le Danub
en 1815. Donc à différentes étapes, on a
créé des règles collectives. Il faut que
les puissances du moment soient
d'accord. Personne respecte les règles.
Regardez le programme américain de de
60000,
c'est pas vrai à ce point. 60000
personnes en en
vous allez me citer que les exemples de
règles non respectées et pas les autres.
Et c'est
les règles sont faites pour être
transgressé.
Non non, elles sont enfin faites pas
pour ça. Elles peuvent l'être et c'est
pas le but. Le but de la règle c'est
l'inverse. C'est trouver un une façon de
vivre en commun quoi.
Ou de la contourner.
Non c'est pas le but. Non mais c'est ce
qui se passe à l'heure actuelle. Quand
quand je je prends un exemple, je prends
un exemple si vous me permettez.
Bien sûr.
Quand certains pays demandent à d'autres
pays du renseignement sur leur propre
leur propre population pour contourner
la loi d'acquérir de l'information sur
sa propre population.
C'est une façon de contourner les
règles.
Oui, mais toutes les règles ont toujours
été plus ou moins contournées. C'est une
lutte sans fin entre les puissances qui
émettent les règles qui dans nos cas
doivent être claires, connues,
démocratiques, délibéré et cetera et
cetera et puis ceux qui essayent de les
contourner. C'est toujours comme donc
tout ce qu'on a essayé de faire au 20e
siècle pour organiser un peu le monde,
ce que les gens appellent naïvement la
communauté internationale qui est pas
encore une communauté en fait.
Pourquoi naïvement ?
Parce qu'il y a pas de communauté.
Il y a que des C'est chacun son Je
Non, c'est pas chacun pour soit mais le
mot communauté dieu pour tous.
Non, c'est trop chaleureux le mot
communauté. Moi, je pense qu'il est
positif.
Donc, c'est Jurassic Park. Oui, un peu.
Et tout le monde a l'opinion publique,
si on peut dire l'opinion publique, a
des lunettes roses.
Il n'empêche que Oui, oui, c'est ce que
je dis moi-même. Et et nous et nous et
nous nous avons euh un qu d'ors qui
pratique le langage
feutré des salons foot.
Non, mais c'est pas vrai ça. Mais non,
encore une fois, le langage feutré,
c'est pour pour pas exciter les gens,
pour rien. C'est idiot. Mais dans les
négociations, ils sont très clairs et
nets, hein.
Est-ce que ce langage est toujours
d'actualité ? Tout il y aura il y aura
toujours
quand vous voyez la Chine
dans différentes sociétés différents
groupes à commencer par les familles une
façon de parler qui au lieu de déchaîner
des conflits inutiles cherchent à
atteindre les résultats sans les
conflits quand vous vous êtes sur
Twitter c'est des professionnels de ça
voyez
vous êtes gauche euh vous êtes sur
Twitter
non
vous avez pas suivi
je suis rien
le le vous vivez avec votre temps le
quand vous voyez vous avez forcément de
de résistance.
Vous lisez le journal, je vous ai vu
arriver avec trois canards sous le bar.
Ah oui, je lis énormément. Oui.
Bon, vous avez suivi le fait que le
Drian convoque l'ambassadeur de Chine
après avoir été hyper agressif et
véhément contre certaines personnes,
il avait dépassé les bornes. Ce langage
diplomatique, le vôtre, il est révolu.
Quand vous voyez la Chine hyper
puissante s'exprimer à travers son
ambassadeur d'une façon agressivement
ouverte,
non. le langage de la responsabilité ne
sera jamais révolu ou alors c'est une de
chaos mondial dans laquelle tout le
monde va perdre. Bon mais dans les
aujourd'hui
revenons sur la géopolitique les
occidentaux avaient on y est, vous avez
raison mais j'y reviens par un autre
biais. Les Américains avaient cru gagner
tout. Fin de l'histoire on contrôle tout
et puis il y a quand même la Chine
émergent. Alors on est dans une phase de
tension. Alors il y a un mélange il y a
un mélange de procédé diplomatique. On
convoque l'ambassadeur pour l'engueuler
mais ça se fait partout. Lesiens le
font, les les Turc le font, les
Israéliens le font, tout le monde le
fait, les Américains le font. Et en même
temps, vous avez autre chose. Par
exemple, les Américains veulent essayer
d'endiguer la Chine par une stratégie
dite indo pacifique. Bon, c'est pas
contradictoire et que le fait de
convoquer un ambassadeur à un moment
donné en lui disant "Cette fois-ci, vous
allez trop loin." Il faut donc faut pas
opposer les deux, c'est pas ridicule. Il
y aura pas que la guerre, il y aura pas
des actions de service secret, il y aura
pas que des cyberapaques généralisés
dans tous les sens, il y aura toute une
panoplie. Voyez ça comme un élément
d'une panoplie. Est-ce que ça suffit ?
Bien sûr que non. Mais la question
derrière, c'est est-ce qu'on va essayer
d'empêcher la Chine de continuer à se
développer ? Comment on va faire ?
Est-ce que les occidentaux sont d'accord
entre eux pour continuer à reléguer la
Russie dans le coin comme si c'était une
menace aussi atroce qu'à l'époque de
l'URS ? Est-ce qu'ils sont d'accord pour
endiguer la Chine ? Même s'il cétait
d'accord, il fréquent. Voyez en fait on
est les occidentaux restent très très
riches, très inventifs, très créatifs en
sécurité. Enfin, c'est tout à fait
extraordinaire d'être en Occident, mais
on n'est plus les maîtres du monde et on
va évidemment pas recoloniser le monde
entier. Voyez ?
Donc on va être obligé de coexister
quand même un moment ou un autre.
Il y a quand même une colonisation
numérique.
Bah disons c'est une c'est une foire
d'empoin plutôt. Il y a pas qu'une
colonie. Alors évidemment les puissances
dominantes dominent à un moment donné de
même qu'à un moment donné l'Europe
dominait puis elle a étendue dans le
monde entier ses chemins de fer et ses
bateaux et ses avions. C'est la
puissance. C'est la puissance mais il
faut pas l'interpréter comme si c'était
sans arrêt d'une sorte d'intention
maline atroce. de de puissances qui nous
veulent du mal. C'est le résultat de de
c'est la puissance, c'est les avancées,
c'est le progrès, c'est ça,
c'est des couteaux dans le dos, c'est
des crochepieds, c'est tout ça
et c'est les spèces humaines ça.
Est-ce que Est-ce que on est le le monde
je dis pas qu'il faut admettre hein, il
faut trouver les bons points d'appui
pour essayer de d'encadrer ça.
On vit dans une société archaïque.
Non
non, c'est peut-être un discours du
monde numérique ça, mais c'est pas vrai.
On continue de se taper dessus. Ah ben
non, arque sur le plan des réflexes
humains. Bah oui, d'accord. L'espèce
humaine, les gens ont peur de plein de
trucs. Vous parler des services vous
parliez des services secrets.
Quel rapport vous avez entretenu avec
les les services secrets ? Est-ce que
les services secrets ont été vos yeux,
vos oreilles ? Comment ça se fonctionne
? très peu parce que d'abord quand
j'étais à l'Élysée même en tant que
secrétaire général, j'étais informé de
ce qu'il disait mais c'est le directeur
de cabinet qui avait le suivi régulier
simplement dès qu'il y avait dans les
rapports hebdomadaires, on va dire, des
indications importantes sur le plan
international, on me les montrait en
général, sauf dans quelques pays que la
France pour des raisons historiques
connaissait plutôt mieux que les autres,
il y avait pas tellement plus que ce
qu'il y avait dans les choses ouvertes.
ou quelqu'un qui lise attentivement la
presse, la les articles de qualité ou
bien les rapports diplomatiques sérieux,
il y avait pas tellement plus à un
moment donné si les services disent
attention il y a un coup d'état qui se
prépare à tel endroit des choses comme
ça. Donc c'était pas un rapport
permanent, c'était pas très important,
ça n'alimentait pas beaucoup ma
réflexion et je dirais encore moins
celle du président euh à quelques
exceptions près. Quand j'étais aux
affaires étrangères, même chose c'est
mon directeur de cabinet qui recevait
les éléments. Ça s'ajoutait pour nous à
des dizaines, pour pas dire des
centaines d'analyses tous les jours sur
toutes les situations dans le monde.
C'était jamais déterminant. Mais j'ai
connu les patrons des services hein, les
patrons de la DGSE, les patrons de la
DST, c'était toujours des gens très bien
très bien qui essayer de tirer le
meilleur partie de la de cet instrument
qui l'élément essentiel c'est pas ce
qu'on trouve dans SS 117 ou SS, c'est le
c'est l'analyse en fait
vous regarde la l'analyse brute
c'est l'analyse qui fait la différence
c'est l'analyse brute. Les services sont
censés faire remonter de l'analyse
brute. En tout cas des faits d'abord des
infos et puis après de l'analyse brute.
Mais il faut l'analyser au second degré
après.
C'est quoi l'analyse brute ? Brut c'est
il semblerait que euh le conflit entre X
et Y se réveille entre tel groupe et tel
autre. Voilà des signes qui peuvent
faire craindre le nouvellement
d'événements inquiétant l'opinion
et c'est tout.
Non mais ça peut être assez riche hein.
Assez riche surtout si sur riche d'info,
je veux dire surtout si c'est des sur
des cheés où les la presse ouverte n'a
pas tellement travaillé. Voyez les pays
non on a oublié on peut pas s'occuper
lecture sur un problème d'interprétation
lecture sur le covid est-ce que le qued
d'ors était pas souris et aveugle est-ce
que les services secrets n'étaient pas
souris et aveugles ?
Non c'est pas ça le sujet. Al d'abord je
vous rappelle que je suis pas la tête du
K d'Orset.
Vous étiez ?
Oui, j'étais.
Mais j'ai quitté en 2002 hein. C'est
pareil.
C'est pas tout à fait pareil.
Ça va faire 20 ans.
Oui. Alors, je suis resté dans le coup.
J'ai je continue à voir les présidents,
les ministres, mener quelques missions
de temps en temps, mais toujours en tant
que comme libre.
Beaucoup de vos collègues travaillent
encore là-bas. Non,
c'est pas le problème du qu d'ors en
tout cas. Le problème de la pandémie. Ce
qui est frappant, c'est que Bill Gates,
les livres blancs sur la défense et la
sécurité des grands pays européens et
plein d'autres les rapports de la CIA,
tout ça avait dit depuis longtemps,
il va y avoir un moment ou un autre une
pandémie respiratoire gravissime
à partir de l'origine n'était pas
détaillée, j'en savai rien mais il dit
il y a un vrai risque et comme quelque
chose de très contagieux, ça fait partie
des grands risques
Les risques écologiques, ça c'est un
grand risque aussi. Et compte tenu de la
du mode de vie contemporain qui est un
mouvement brodien où tout le monde
circule dans tous les sens sans qu'on
puisse les arrêter, ça se répondra très
vite.
Ça était tellement
c'est pas une question de ked je sais
pas quoi ou des ministères dans les
autres pays. C'est un problème mondial,
c'est pas une question française.
Je peux vous stopper une seule chose ?
tellement laissez-moi juste une phrase
ça interpelle tellement la
mondialisation
telle qu'elle était devenue le droit
d'aller là où on veut quand on veut
comme on veut sans aucune règle et que
c'était impensable pour des autorités en
disant mais que faire par rapport à ça
voyez et les seuls pays qui bien
réagissent c'est les pays d'Asie du
Sud-Est qui avaient on n'avait pas
oublié le SRAS et qui avait tiré des
leçons et qui s'étaient organisé dans
tous les autres pays en gros qu'à
fouiller, il faudra tirer des leçons de
tout ça.
C'est pas du tout un problème français,
hein.
Quand quand on on entend notre notre
administration Macron et les herzates de
de LREM dire vous rendez pas compte,
personne n'avait anticipé ça, on a on a
été en première ligne, on a été obligé
de s'organiser. pour que nous qui
faisons de l'intelligence économique,
qui lisons le rapport de la CIA,
nous savions bien que ça nous
pendaitonnait. Comment vous jugez ce ce
discours politique, ces incantations
politiques ? C'est une façon de calmer
sa population en se déresponsabilisant
la la l'institution ? Non mais moi j'ai
pas grand dire euh vous m'avez invité en
théorie après ce dictionnaire amoureux
de la géopolitique
et là c'est de la politique intérieure,
ça m'intéresse pas. Donc je pense pas
d'ailleurs que la France s'en sorte plus
mal que d'état d'autres. Je crois en
revanche
diplomate
non je crois je crois en revanche que
quand on en sera sorti en vrai pas ça
commence à aller beaucoup mieux. On voit
l'optimisme qui revient. C'est très
sympathique. Je pense qu'en 2022
environ, il faut faire une évaluation
systématique dans le monde entier des
politiques de tous les gouvernements, de
toutes les institutions, pas que l'OMS
et aussi les autres surveillance,
détection,
alarme, information, coopération,
confinement, déconfinement, vaccin pour
en tirer les bonnes pratiques
et réformer
et réformer peut-être en cascade des tas
de trucs pour prendre de meilleures
précautions. les bonnes pratiques. Les
bonnes pratiques, c'est comment réagir
vite et mieux et on sera mieux. Il y
aura eu des débats absolument sans fin.
Mais les épidémiologie se sont contredit
parce que c'était assez nouveau en fait,
même si c'était envisagé comme un
risque. Les médecins se contredivent ce
qu'il est malheureux, il sait pas trop
quoi faire au début mais les virologues
non. Les virologues ont tous dit que
développement, urbanisation,
déforestation,
concentration
concentration, ça déconfine les virus.
Alors après, il y a le tourisme de masse
et cetera. Bon, il faut tirer des leçons
de tout ça, mais c'est très compliqué
parce que ça met en jeu ce qui était
devenu la mondialisation sans entrave,
voyez.
Mais les gens vont s'adapter, on va on
va inventer des Et alors peut-être qu'en
plus le paradoxe ça aura été
l'accélération incroyable des travaux
sur les vaccins. incroyable en un an par
des procédés typiquement capitalistes
hein plus l'argent public mis par Trump
et d'autres
surtout l'argent public
les deux les équipes qui travaillaient
mais qui passaient l'argent public mais
après la compétition l'argent public mis
dans des entreprises et des labos de
recherche en compétition entre eux ce
qui aiguisé les choses. Bon si les j'ai
le regret de dire que si les vaccins ont
été décrétés comme étant des biens
publics mondiaux gérés par une agence
des Nations Unies toujours pas de vaccin
voyez donc il faut combiner et je pense
qu'il peut y avoir des retombées
positives de cette pandémie qui par
ailleurs ne change rien à la
géopolitique ça la
simplement ça l'intensifie ça ça
l'accélère ça lagrave on voit mieux
l'affaire Chine États-Unis voyez mais
tous les problèmes énormes du monde
était là avant.
Il faut que de cet accélérateur
pandémique sorte des progrès. Voilà,
on va essayer de vous poser une question
pour vous déconcentrer un petit peu.
Question d'internet, de CB. Quel était
le danger du Rainbow Warrior ? Quel
risque présentaient ces militants ? Le
risque existe-t-il encore aujourd'hui ?
Alors, ça n'existe plus aujourd'hui
puisqu'il y a plus d'essai en fait.
C'est quoi le Rainbow Warrior ? Alors le
Ron Warrior c'est une c'est une affaire
une affaire qui a malheureusement mal
tourné en s fait choper
en 80
2 je crois
et si je me rappelle bien en tout cas
c'est au début du Septénat de François
Mitéran c'est une époque où il y a
encore des essais nucléaires dans le
Pacifique
à des milliers de distances de pap
essais qui avaient lieu comme ils
avaient lieu sur Giscar sur Pompidou sur
Dogu à l'époque de Dogu Pompidou C'était
encore au Sahara. Il y a des essais
réguliers pour mettre au point les
nouvelles les nouvelles bombes, les
ajuster. Voyez l'époque où il y a encore
des toutes les puissances nucléaires
font des essais
font des essais à l'extérieur.
La seule puissance qui est qui est
l'objet d'une condamnation et d'une
surveillance c'est la France. Alors ça
n'arrive pas par exemple à propos des
essais britanniques qui avaient lieu au
milieu de l'Australie. Enfin bon, c'est
une parenthèse ça. Char Warrior. Donc
chaque année, il y avait un programme
les essais nucléaires israéliens.
Oui, c'est encore plus secret ça. Et
Liberty, vous en pensez quoi ?
Attendez, j'ai pas fini sur le Briur.
Donc chaque année,
bateau
chaque année, il y avait des mesures de
précaution qui étaient prises pour
empêcher des bateaux de militants
écologistes d'aller vers la zone là où
ils auraient été en danger. Il fallait
pas laisser arriver un accident, ça
aurait été déplorable. Donc il y avait
des mesures pour les empêcher de de
passer en général par des des barrages
de bateau, des j'imagine des sabotages
de bateaux, des choses comme ça. Ça
avait lieu tout le temps, tout le temps.
Chaque fois qu'il y avait une campagne
d'essai. Donc le Méran a donné
l'instruction de continuer. Il y a dû
avant la fermari, il y en a certainement
eu d'autres qui n'ont pas mal tourné. Et
très malheureusement, il se trouve
qu'une équipe de la DGSE avait dynamité
un bateau qui devait donc couler et ne
pas aller sur lui quand il y avait
personne dedans. Il y a un malheureux
gars qui était un photographe portugais
si je me rappelle bien même si je me
suis pas du tout du tout occupé de ces
affairesl mais enfin je je sais quand
même il est revenu dans le bateau au
moment où la bombe a sauté. Donc il y a
un type qui est mort là-dedans qui qui
était pleurable. L'idée générale puisque
c'était ça la question c'était d' de
protéger d'empêcher les bateaux de
militants écologistes d'aller trop près
de la zone
par tous les moyens.
Non pas par tous les moyens pas pas en
supprimant des gens. Ça c'était jamais
fait c'était il mettait des produits
dans le dans le moteur pour que ça
marche plus des trucs comme ça voyez. Et
pour des raisons que je connais pas
d'ailleurs. Mais ça entraîné la la
démission du ministre de l'époque
Charles Hernue. Voyez ? Oui,
c'est bien déplorable, mais l'intention
était de, je le répète, de protéger les
militants écologiques qui voulaient
aller se rapprocher de la zone pour
faire des photos.
Vous avez lu le bouquin euh euh de
François Hollande concernant euh
tout ce qu'un président ne doit pas
dire. Comment c'était le titre déjà ?
Euh, je crois que c'est ça le titre. Je
l'ai feuilleté, j'ai pas lu en entier.
Oui.
On a toujours des assassins qui se
baladent un peu partout qui
s'affranchissent de nos tribunaux. Non
mais la la question du livre c'est
est-ce qu'il fallait faire ce livre ?
Tout est dans le titre d'ailleurs
est-ce qu'il fallait voter pour lui ?
Non, c'est autre chose. Je suis pas là
pour parler politique intérieure
parce que dans la liberté que j'ai
conquise par ma décision de 2002 de pas
aller sur le terrain politique et puis
de m'intéresser à la géopolitique, à
d'autres sujets, à la photo et cetera,
il y a aussi la liberté de pas être de
pas répondre à des questions d'actualité
politique ou de conjoncture politique.
C'est un panier de crable la politique ?
Non, pas plus que tous les milieux
compétitifs.
Je pense que les artistes en compétition
entre eux, les médias en compétition
entre eux, les entreprises en
compétition pour obtenir des grands
marchés, les banquiers d'affaires en
compétition pour obtenir un mandat,
c'est des milieux les milieux sportifs,
c'est des milieux de compétition
compétition. Alors évidemment, c'est
aggravé. Si vous avez raison, il y a un
élément aggravant, c'est que
il y a plein de milieux en compétition
mais qui sont pas obligés d'exprimer
leurs états d'ames toute la journée et
qui sont pas obligés de répondre à des
tas de questions tout le temps. Disent
que dans la dimension, il y a la
compétition, les gens veulent être élus,
donc les autres veulent être élus à leur
place, ils ont compétition. C'est aussi
banal qu'un tournoi de tennis, hein.
Mais ils sont obligés de parler, de
commenter
et comme la plupart d'entre eux n'ont
pas la force de résister aux demandes
permanentes et qui se sont égravés, pas
avec la presse écrite, c'était
différent, mais les médias et puis
l'information continue et les réseaux
sociaux. Donc sans arrêt, on leur
demande de réagir à ceci, cela. Un tel a
dit "Vous étiez un imbécile, qu'est-ce
que vous pensez ? C'est lui qui est un
imbécile ?" Bon, c'est effrayant. Donc
il faudrait faudra reconstruire une
resélectionner une classe politique
d'avenir où les gens soient pas obligés
de se plier à ce jeu. Donc il y a la
compétition mais c'est un peu pire à
cause de la l'exhibitionnisme, la
demande de transparence, le narcissisme
et compagnie mais la base c'est la
compétition quand même.
La mégalomanie politique, dites-moi, on
fait quoi ?
Ça c'est encore autre chose ça. La
mégalomanie.
Oui, mais c'est dans certains cas une
une indispensable en fait.
Pourquoi dans certains métiers ? Parce
que c'est tellement dur. C'est tellement
dur.
Vous êtes tellement étrié, tellement
tellement pour chasser, tellement bon.
Donc il faut un peu un peu de mégal
peut-être pas trop quoi, mais un peu un
soupçon de mégalomanie.
C'est vrai, je dirais ça des artistes
aussi hein.
On fait quoi avec Erdogan ? On fait quoi
avec les flux migratoires ?
Alors flux migratoire, c'est un immense
sujet. Erdogan, c'est un sujet compliqué
mais plus spécifique. Sur le flux
migratoire,
moi j'ai une position très simple. Il
faut reprendre le contrôle des flux
migratoires.
C'est pas possible de raisonner en
disant tout le monde a le droit d'aller
où il veut. C'est impossible. On peut
pas non plus raisonner comme il y a très
très longtemps en France, les grandes
entreprises à main d'œuvre Gur
automobile avait besoin qu'on fasse
venir des gars de Kabili, du fond de
l'atlace et cetera. Bon après il y a le
regroupement familial
sous Giscar Chirac que bar voulait
annuler pour des raisons de chômage en
France que le Conseil d'État rétabli,
qui s'est développé et cetera et cetera
et cetera. Bon aujourd'hui,
je pense que
les fl migratoires sont trop importants
bien sûr que le Schengen qui est une
bonne idée au départ la libre
circulation en Europe, c'est sympa comme
idée mais ça s'est développé dans une
ambiance justement optimiste un peu
naïve dont on parlait au début de notre
conversation et on n pas travaillé la
frontière extérieure
et une époque
vraiment utopique de la construction
européenne en disant la frontière
extérieure, on verra, on sait pas où
c'est, on fait rentrer d'autres pays, on
va élargir tout ça. Donc il y avait une
sorte de période un peu sans frontiè,
voyez, liberté de circulation. Sauf que
quand on en arrive à des flux comme les
flux des dernières années, ce n'est plus
gérable.
Comment on fait pour reprendre le
contrôle ? Alors,
il faut une il faudrait C'est compliqué,
je sais bien que c'est compliqué, il
faudrait une négociation annuelle ou
bisannuelle avec les pays de départ. de
transit et d'arrivée arrivé chez
Schengen. Donc il faut refaire Schengen
avec des pays capables de contrôler les
mouvements et des pays dont les
frontières sont pas commodes à gérer,
hein. Bon à partir de là, on discuterait
par quota le métier, pas par quota par
pays, ça n'aurait pas de sens, par
métier en fonction des besoins de
l'économie européenne et en fonction de
la capacité d'absorption dans des
conditions correctes. les gens puissent
venir travailler en étant bien reçu et
cetera et cetera puis renvoyer de
l'argent à leur famille tout. Faut le
relégaliser, faut le remettre dans des
circuits normaux négociés et on tombe
sur la question du droit d'asile. Le
droit d'asile, c'est fondamental. C'est
aussi vieux que l'asile dans les églises
au Moyen-Âge. C'est aussi vieux que
l'âme européenne, on va dire. Bon, il
faut préserver le droit d'asile. Sauf
que en pratique aujourd'hui, le droit
d'asile est massivement détourné. il est
détourné
pour comme un moyen d'immigration
illégal déguisé et toutes les structures
qui gèrent les demandeurs d'asile en
Europe sont saturées. Elles n'y arrivent
plus. En plus, c'est très organisé parce
qu'il y a des réseaux jusqu'au fond de
l'Afrique ou de l'Asie. Il y a des
réseaux qui en se faisant payer cher,
des réseaux de passeurs très compétents
qui indiquent aux gens par où ils
doivent passer au péril de leur vie
souvent et quand ils arrivent dans quel
pays il faut rentrer, quelle demande il
faut présenter, quel dossier il faut
imaginer pour avoir peut-être les par
quels avocats il faut passer, quels ONG
a toute une sorte de de système
gigantesque qui est tragique qui est
tragique parce qu'en plus les souvent
les gens qui quittent des ces pays
prenant des pays d'Afrique de l'Ouest
par exemple, il y en a d'autres, c'est
des gens très
C'est des gens jeunes, dynamiques,
courageux qui vont partir avec l'argent
du village ou de la famille pour payer
les passeurs dont certains vont mourir
en route, qui sont prêts à prendre des
risques gigantesques. C'est des gens qui
sont vitaux pour leur pays en plus. Donc
les tous les gens qui sont généreux, ce
qu'on peut comprendre, c'est à la toute
l'histoire la charité chrétienne en
Europe, qui disent "Faut aider les gens,
faut les insérer ceci cela". Oui, il
faut le faire naturellement pour les les
gens déjà arrivés dans dans la situation
peut-être pathétique éventuellement,
mais il faut couper le flux. Faut couper
le flux. Donc moi, je suis pas choqué
que Michel Barnier par exemple il y a
quelques temps et il parlait d'un
moratoire d'un moratoire sur les flux
migratoires pour qu'on ait le temps de
se réorganiser. Mais sauf il faut sauver
l'asile. Je viens de dire il y a 2
minutes qu'il était massivement détourné
mais il faut le sauver. Comment le
sauver ? il faut le reconcentrer
sur les gens vraiment en danger. Ça
c'est le sens des conventions
internationales. Sont en danger pour des
raisons de de race, de sexe, de
religion, d'opinion politique ou alors
de guerre de guerre civile comme en
Syrie. Et la plupart des réfugiés de la
Syrie, ils sont en Turquie. Et quand ils
quittent la Turquie, ils sont pas en
situation de demandeur d'asile en fait,
ils sont en situation d'migrants à ce
moment-là. Voilà. Donc, il faut remettre
de l'ordre là-dedans et ça passera par
un un jour il y aura un grand sommet qui
sera très violent d'ailleurs très
conflictuel entre le Schengen
reconstitué, les pays de départ et
transit. tout le monde va hurler, va
gueuler en demandant des indemnisations,
ceci cela et il faut nous aider à
financer les douiniers, les machins.
Bon, on peut pas y échapper sinon c'est
tragique hein. C'est tragique parce que
ça va contribuer à à corroder, à
déstabiliser les les sociétés
européennes avec des votes extrémistes
d'extrême gauche, d'extrême droite dans
dans tous les sens. Donc il faut
vraiment remettre de l'ordre pas pour
fermer. Encore une fois, on peut pas se
passer de l'immigration. On a besoin
pour des raisons économiques. Ce serait
humainement cruel et en plus
inapplicable. Donc pour remettre des
règles un peu comme ce qu'on disait sur
la mondialisation. La question turque,
elle est à la fois la même et c'est
différent.
La Turquie c'est un des pays qui sont
révisionnistes
au sens où ils acceptent pas les règles
du jeu fixé par les vainqueurs de la
guerre de 14. rendez compte,
il faut remonter au traité de
de Sèvre et de Lausanne ou alors
ou alors il faut remonter à l'après la
deuxième guerre mondiale.
Donc la Turquie qu'on avait cru
moderniser
une sorte de pays musulman d'origine de
culture mais en fait très moderne très
laïque turque avait complètement changé
son pays brutalement hein dans les
années 20 inspiré par le modèle français
modèle français notamment la laïcité et
c'est c'était considéré comme acquis et
d'ailleurs quand après la guerre les
Américains ont mis les Grecs la Grèce et
la Turquie dans l'OTAN pour avoir deux
pays de l'OTAN sous euh sur le flanc sud
de l'URS, personne n'ait mis
d'objection.
Ça paraissait le sens de l'histoire. Et
quand la Turquie a été candidate à
l'Union européenne, certains ont dit
"Bon, c'est pas vraiment un pays
d'Europe, mais enfin quand même tout ça,
finalement la candidature a été acceptée
en 99.
Aujourd'hui, ça serait pas le cas.
Si la Turquie n'était pas dans le temps,
les Américains mettraient pas la Turquie
dans le temps et la candidature turque
serait pas accepté. De toute façon, même
s'il y avait un traité d'allésion, il
serait pas ratifié par les 27. Donc on a
on a menti au Turc. Là, c'était vraiment
la pour pas oser dire les choses comme
elles sont. Alors pour le coup, vous
pourriez reprendre vos critiques sur la
langue de Wi là parce que c'était une
espèce de d'arrangement un peu
faussement aimable et faussement
courtois fondé sur une hypocrisie et
cetera et cetera. Donc la Turquie serait
de toute façon jamais rentré dans
l'Union européenne. Sur ce arrive
Erdogan. Il eu plusieurs partis
islamiques, d'autres leader et Erdogan
dit maintenant tout ça c'est fini. La
Turquie doit reprendre toute sa place.
Toute sa place. Il récuse non seulement
le traité qui avait dépessé la Turquie
après la le traité de Sèvre, mais le
traité de Lausanne 3 ans après qui était
moins pire et quand même moins pire,
sauf que l'Empire ottoman a disparu,
hein. Donc la la Grandagne, la
Grande-Bretagne et la France était
partagé le
ce qui est devenu la Syrie ou redevenu
la Syrie et l'Irak et la Palestine et
cetera et cetera. Voilà. Donc Erdogan,
il surfle là-dessus. Il a réveillé un
nationalisme turc. Il a même été
au-delà. Il a émis la prétention de
refaire l'Empire ottoman. Ça peut pas
marcher. Aucun pays arabe ne veut
naturellement. Donc il est dans une
espèce de fuite en avant déclaratoire
et sur le plan intérieur marche pas très
bien. L'économie n'est pas terrible. Il
a relancé la lutte contre les Kurdes
parce que les Turcs considèrent que si
un état kurde, ils sont foutus parce que
ça empute à nouveau un/ers du pays.
Enfin, donc il y a une sorte de
nationalisme très grand. Et ils sont
donc révisionnistes comme les un peu
Poutine sur certains points ou comme les
la Chine à cause des traités inégaux du
19e siècle. Les puissances qui disent le
monde organisé par les occidentaux, par
les Américains en 1918 et en 1945, nous
c'est pas notre truc.
Ils vont pas tout rejeter hein. Ils vont
pas tout rejeter mais ils veulent
contester sur certains points.
Bon alors que faire ? On a pas un choix
très netin parce que nous les Européens
quand le président Macron a juste titre
à protester contre les comportements
turcs en Méditerranée
par exemple la Chypre ou et cetera, la
France a été soutenue par six pays sur
30 au sein de l'OTAN.
Parce que les Américains et le système
botien disent peut-être Erdogan est
insupportable, il est peut-être
dangereux sur plan mais on peut pas se
passer de la Turquie.
La guerre en Libye, vous portez quel
regard dessus ? sûr.
La guerre en Libye.
La guerre en Libye. Euh alors je pense à
l'origine hein à l'origine je pense que
Nikel Sarkozy n'a pas eu tort. Enfin je
comprends sa décision quand il y avait
le début des printemps arabes une
révolte de Bengazi
que Kadfier son fils avait dit "On va
noyer la révolte dans une rivière de
sang". Il l'aurait fait. Donc je
comprends assez la réaction initiale
en disant avec les anglais soutien
américain en disant on intervient, on
vous empêche de faire ça. Donc jusqu'à
un éventuel disons bombardement des
colonnes de blindé, je comprends, c'est
une réaction peut-être trop droit de la
mise, peut-être trop liée. On
pas on avait pas le le mandat pour ça
le
le mandat pour maintenir on avait juste
le mandat pour pquer d'avion qui se
balade dans le ciel. Oui, c'est pour ça
que j'allais dire que s'il y avait eu la
première action Oui, d'accord. On
pouvait déborder un peu de la première
action pour empêcher un peu
pour empêcher le massacre de Bengazi. En
revanche,
c'était pas de l'intox ça le massacre
les colonnes de char et tout le
tinttoin.
En tout cas, char ou pas char, les
menaces de cadfié étaient implosibles,
hein. Vu l'animal et son fils, ils
auraient massacré hein. Il aurait
massacré, il l' déjà fait. Donc c'était
pas inventé complètement. Mais donc moi
pas complètement
ben je veux dire par là que c'était
peut-être exagéré mais c'était pas
inventé complètement ça partait pas de
rien. Donc moi je suis compréhensif.
Alors en plus avec mes 20 années au
pouvoir et fait que j'ai gardé le
contact avec les gens de pouvoir un peu
partout, je sais que c'est tellement
compliqué que je suis en général assez
indulgent. Voyez, je cherche pas la la
critique facile sur les décisions prises
par les uns et les autres. Je reviens à
la Libye. Si on avait empêché le
massacre de de Bengazi en disant un cas
non, vous arrêtez vraiment, vous arrêtez
sinon on va faire voter un mandat
vraiment pour éliminer votre système, il
aurait peut-être été prêt à composer. Il
avait été impressionné par Ran quelques
années avant, vous savez. Et et donc je
pense que la première toute première
étape se peut se comprendre. La suite
non. Alors après donc Kaddafi est
renversé, il est pourchassé, il est
traqué, il est assassiné. La Libye se
décompose. Ça jamais été un état la
Libye, il y a plusieurs plusieurs zones
tripolitaines, syrianiques, le faisant
et cetera. Et ce qui existait déjà un
peu avant, c'est-à-dire le fait que la
Libye serve de passage tous les trafics,
y compris les trafics d'immigration qui
sont une sorte d'esclavage moderne. La
pauvre Afrique, l'esclavage a dominé, ça
fait plus de 1000 ans que ça domine en
Afrique. C'est atroce. Bon, donc à
partir de là, on a l'aggravation.
Après, ce qui est dommage, c'est que
les Français et les Libyens,
excusez-moi, j'ai fait une erreur. Les
Français et les Italiens et les Italiens
ont jamais réussi à se mettre d'accord
tout à fait sur quoi faire en Libye en
soutenant les uns ou les autres et
cetera et les et c'était pas les mêmes
leaders qui étaient soutenus par les
Égyptiens ou par les Tunisiens et
cetera. Il semble qu'on arrive
maintenant quand même à un consensus
relatif. Il y aura peut-être des
élections donc on va peut-être sortir de
la séquence des troubl mais on est
obligé de revenir à l'origine de ça.
Voyez ça aurait été mieux je dis
cyniquement et brutalement d'avoir un un
colonel Kaddafi impressionné
sous menace et c
sous sanction sous sanction.
Nous les sanctions c'est souvent un
usage interne. La plupart des cas les
démocraties votent des sanctions parce
que ça fait plaisir à l'opinion interne.
C'est très rare que les sanctions
soutions. Ouais. Les sanctions contre la
Russie ça sert à rien en fait.
Ça sert à calmer l'opinion américaine
par exemple ou française ou allemande.
Alors il y a quelques sanctions dans
l'histoire qui sont utiles. Un moment
donné on cite toujours l'exemple de
l'Afrique du Sud bien sûr mais dans la
plupart des cas non.
D'abord, l'objectif est rarement clair.
C'est souvent des sanctions de punition.
Donc s de mélange entre le la
diplomatie, le réalisme et la morale,
une sorte de miliméo. Après, souvent
c'est les peuples qui en souffrent
pendant les sanctions américaines contre
Saddam Hussein après la guerre couvette,
hein. C'est évidemment les populations
irakiennes qui en souffrait le plus.
C'est pour ça qu'ils se sont
radicalisés, que ça a permis à Al-Qaïda
de puler là-bas. Mais
c'est c'est pour ça que les quand la
population est est prise sous le jou des
sanctions.
Oui.
est-ce que ça ne favorise pas la
radicalisation ?
Oui, ça c'est pas le seul facteur mais
ça peut ça peut jouer un rôle. Sous
Saddam Hussein, c'était pas le tableau
quand même. Saddam Hussein était un
dictateur féroce, absolument féroce, qui
avait réprimé qui avait envahi le
cowette pour mettre la main sur le
coffre fort, qui avait réprimé
férocement les Chites, qui avait essayé
de réprimer les Kurdes, mais la France
avait obtenu de l'uni qui une zone
d'exclusion aérienne. C'est c'est une
des quelques idées que que Mitteran
avait accepté de Bernard Kouchner à
l'époque, je signale parce qu'il en a
pas eu tellement en fait. Mais ça
c'était très bien, très bien. Mais
Saddam Hussein était resté un dictateur
impitoyable pour son propre peuple, vous
voyez par rapport à ça. Et donc les
sanctions évidemment aggrav ça parce que
les sanctions appauvrissaient le peuple
irraquin. C'est souvent le cas. Donc
moi, je suis très réticent par rapport
aux sanctions. Mais dans les démocraties
modernes, le poids de l'opinion, la
surexcitation de l'opinion avec tout ce
qu'on a décrit et rappelé hein,
l'information continue, réseaux sociaux
et cetera, c'est tellement violent.
que dans quelques cas les gouvernants
peuvent pas résister, même si c'est pas
un instrument très intelligent, même
s'il faudrait raisonner autrement, faire
autrement. Alors à mon époque, moi
j'avais beaucoup bataillé et obtenu
qu'on ne vote jamais des sanctions
définitives
et qu'on vote des sanctions que pour une
durée déterminée déterminée pour pouvoir
reraisonner au bout d'un an, au bout de
6 mois. Est-ce que ça vaut vraiment le
coup ? Est-ce qu'il y a pas une autre
approche ? ça s'appliquerait à toutes
sortes de cas dont la Russie par
exemple. Voyez aujourd'hui
malheureusement mon idée n'a pas
fonctionné
et dans la plupart des cas aucun pays du
groupe qui sanctionne conseil de
sécurité Europe par exemple n'ose
prendre l'initiative de dire on ne va
pas reconduire. Donc il y a une sorte de
pression et pour les gouvernements c'est
c'est assez commode hein de dire oui je
suis extrêmement ferme dans tel cas on
va voter des sanctions nouvelles et
cetera ça sert à rien fondamentalement
ça sert à rien la question de la Russie
quoi qu'on pense du régime russe et de
ces manœuvres qui sont réelles et de on
peut lui reprocher plein de trucs la
Russie sera toujours à côté de nous en
fait ça sera jama toujours la Russie
c'est pas un pays d'Asie c'est pas un
pays d'Europe c'est autre chose. Donc je
suis par expérience très très réticent
mais je peux pas aller je peux pas aller
jusqu'à dire de façon démagogique qu'il
faut jamais de sanction. C'est
intenable, ça marchera jamais.
Demain, il y a le président Macron qui
va se balader au Rwanda.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ? Est-ce
que vous pouvez nous nous résumer ce
qu'a été le Rwanda ?
C'est trop compliqué pour être résumé.
Il il y a de il y a deux tests tout à
fait contradictoires sur la pas sur le
génocide qui est contesté par personne
mais sur la politique de la France. Je
dirais que moi je distingue deux choses.
Comment c'est parti déjà ? Attendez, je
distingue deux choses. Que le président
Macron veuille normaliser les relations
avec le Rwanda qui est un tout petit
pays mais enfin influent quand même en
Afrique, je trouve ça ça me pose aucun
problème.
Et personnellement quand j'ai été
ministre j'ai été voir deux fois Kagamé
le président du Rwand le patron du FPR
l'organisation cré en Ouganda à partir
des réfugiés Tutsi pour tenter de
revenir au Rwanda et cetera et cetera
puis devenu président
et et donc moi je l'ai rencontré deux
fois donc l'idée d'avoir des relations
normales me pose aucun problème.
En revanche la question de la vérité
historique qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
vraiment ? Je parle pas du génocide
encore une fois qui que personne ne
discute hein mais sur la politique
française, il y a eu un en France une
énorme ouverture des archives sous
Jospin dans la commission dite quiess
caseuve et puis récemment sous le
président Macron la commission du Cler
qui est un rapport que je trouve moi
tout à fait contestable enfin il existe
pourquoi
il est je vous dire pourquoi. En tout
cas, ce qui est frappant pour moi, c'est
qu'il y a que la France qui a ouvert ces
archives pour le moment.
Donc que le rapport du clair soit une
étape, c'est est évident, c'est une
étape dans la connaissance de tout ça.
Pour avoir une vision complète, il
faudra connaître les archives du Rwanda,
de la Belgique, de l'Ouga, du tribunal
d'Aroucha, de l'ONU, de la
Grande-Bretagne et des États-Unis
et même d'Israël. Puisque l'Israéliens
ont quelques archives qui soutenaient
l'Ouanda. Ils ont dit qu'il ne les
ouvrirait pas. Et moi, j'appelle à ça.
D'ailleurs, ça a été demandé il y a
plusieurs années déjà. Alors, pour le
moment, la France a fait un travail
précis. Là-dessus, je pense qu'il faut
que les autres contribuent. Je parle de
la vérité historique sur les événements,
mais la normalisation me pose pas de
problème. Après tout, je suis un
réaliste. Il faut qu'on ait des
relations, disons les plus normales
possibles avec tous les tous les
régimes.
Qu'est-ce que dit le rapport du CLI ?
C'est quoi la deuxième thèse ? Alors,
les deux thèses, la première thèse,
c'est de dire ça, c'est la thèse euh
Mitteran mais également Jupé ou Baladur,
hein. La France a détecté dès le
déclenchement de la guerre civile en
par Kagamé et le FPR qui avait un risque
monstrueux de guerre civile atroce parce
qu'il y avait eu en 62 à la fin des
Belges des
Ça c'est la DGSE qui détecte ça.
Non, la DG même pas de bureau à la
Rwanda. Non non, c'est une évidence.
Pour Mitéran qui avait connu l'Afrique,
il se rappelaiit très bien des massacres
horribles de 62 contre les Touts et il
voyait que la l'attaque de Kagamé en 90
redéclencher la guerre civile. Bon, donc
ça c'est la la thèse mitérandienne,
c'est la France est le seul pays au
monde qui a vu le risque qui a donc
décidé d'en faire une opération
militaire de soutien, pas direct mais de
soutien pour empêcher que le FPR des
prenne le pouvoir par la force.
et en utilisant cette présence pour
obliger les uns et les autres à un
compromis qui a finalement eu lieu en
1993 à Roucha. À Roucha, c'est là où ont
lieu les réunions parce que c'est là où
il y a les hôtels à cause du tourisme
dans Tanzanie. Donc un accord en 93 et
la France après 93 se retire sur si on
reprenait les médias de l'époque, on
serait étonné parce que c'est le
contraire de ce qu'ils disent ces
dernières années. Et en août 93, on dit
bah oui, il y a un compromis à Roucha,
c'est formidable. Il y a un accord,
c'est pas que grâce à la France. Ça a eu
d'autres puissances. Les États-Unis ont
soutenu le l'Union africaine était très
bien, la Tanzanie était très bien et les
les Touti les Outou accepte l'accord
disons qu'ils vont partager le pouvoir
d'une façon d'ailleurs assez favorable
au tout. Après quoi la France s'en va ?
La France s'en va et elle le relais est
passé une force des nations unies qui
s'appelle la minuard. la minuard. Après
quoi ? Et ben c'est les c'est le c'est
les Rwandais quoi. Et les Randés ils
discutent entre eux, ils mettent pas en
œuvre vraiment l'accord et en avril
suivant l'avion du président du Burundi
et du Runda est abattu.
Par qui ?
On sait pas encore. On sait toujours
pas. Toujours les deux thèses.
J'ai lu,
il y a toujours les deux thèses
extrémistes ou tout. J'ai lu j'ai lu un
rapport j'ai lu un rapport balistique
euh euh hier soir
sur euh comment on tire un missile Sam
16.
À quoi ça ressemble les numéros de
séries, les stocks, à quoi ça ressemble
un missile Sam 16 qui a été tiré ? Un
missile Sams qui n'a pas été tiré, une
coiffe de missile, une trajectoire, une
frappe double de nuit, une acquisition
thermique.
Oui. Alors,
vous l'avez lu ? Vous l'avez lu ce
rapport balistique ?
Non, moi je m'en suis jamais
spécialement occupé. Je m'en suis occupé
ces dernières années parce que la
polémique a est relancée tous les ans
par les mêmes. Donc, j'ai regardé mais
c'est qui les mêmes ?
Comment
c'est qui les mêmes ? Ben, c'est une
série de soit de médias, soit de
chercheurs, soit de personnalités qui
ont qui ont pris partie pour la thèse,
l'autre thèse. Alors, j'ai résumé la
thèse disons favorable à Mitteran euh
Jupé Baladur, y compris moi même si je
me suis jamais occupé euh de la
politique africaine là-dessus, mais je
l'ai défendu quand même. J'ai toujours
défendu, j'essaie de l'expliquer le
mieux possible. Alors l'autre thèse,
c'est la thèse qui a été lancée par le
Gam Kigali mais pas au début en fait
plusieurs années après quand le génocide
c'est 94
et plusieurs années après le juge Bruger
arrive à la conclusion dans l'affaire de
l'avion que c'est sans doute organisé
par le FPR de Paul Kagamé et il lance
des mandats d'arrêt. Et d'ailleurs ce
qui va dans ce sens c'est que des
proches de Kagamé qui avaient pris le
pouvoir avec lui qui l'ont quitté après
des gens importants qui étaient ministre
ou et cetera, se sont réfugiés en
Afrique du Sud et ont déclaré que
c'était eux qui avaient fait l'attentat.
Moi, j'en sais rien. J'ai pas les
éléments pour juger. Ils ont donné les
détails de l'organisation y compris des
missiles qui venaient de l'armée de
l'Ouganda et cetera et cetera. Qui
qui a donné les détails des missiles ?
Je sais pas, écoutez, j'ai pas je suis
pas venu avec 30 kg de truc. Je vous dis
simplement que vous me dites l'autre
thèse, hein. Et donc les anciens de
Kagamé qui en Afrique du Sud avaient dit
ça, l'un d'entre eux est assassiné
et les deux autorités sud-africaines ont
confirmé qu'il était assassiné par les
Rwandais par rapport à ça. Et moi j'ai
pas d'avis et quelque part c'est pas mon
problème parce que s'ils l'avion été
abattu par des extrémistes
ou par des extrémistes tout c'est la
même raison c'est qu'il voulait mettre
fin à la politique de compromis de la
France
dans dans les deux cas donc du point de
vue français ça me paraît
Attendez attendez
alors non mais vous m' poser une
question précise laissez-moi répondre ou
alors il on va passer 8h sur le sujet
j'aime autant de tenter de résumer alors
l'autre thèse qui a été lancée par le
rapport fait par les autorités de qui a
après les accusations de Bruger et pour
répondre à Bruger c'est un truc qui
s'appelle le rapport Miau
mais qui remonte pas au génocide qui
remonte à 2008 consistant à dire tout
est de la faute de la France et depuis
notamment en France mais pas dans les
autres pays d'ailleurs le l'ancien
spécialiste de l'Afrique à Libé Stephen
Smith dit qu'il y a une exception
française à ce sujet parce qu'il y a
qu'en France qu'on peut lire les
accusations contre la France qui
continuent en tout cas l'autre C'est
c'est de la faute de la France. Alors
c'est repris périodiquement notamment
tous les ans et ça été repris pas
entièrement mais en partie par le
rapport du clair et cette commission qui
la France qui dit que la France a une
responsabilité.
Non le rapport du Cler commence par dire
qu'il n'y a pas de complicité. Non mais
non mais soyons précis. Pendant des
pendant des années, y compris monsieur
Ducler lui-même,
il disait "La France a été complice."
L'opération turquoise qui était liée
après quand la France était partie
d'ailleurs, elle est revenue avec
l'accord après mais elle était partie au
moment des US plus là plusieurs mois.
Donc du clair, pas du clair,
excusez-moi, mais les attaquants
disaient la France est complice.
L'opération turquoise a dissimuler des
opérations de soutien donc auou et
cetera et cetera. Oui.
Le rapport du claire
partant de opinion négative. Il suffit
de voir les interviews du président de
la commission, monsieur Ducler, avant
qu'il ait commencé les travaux. Ils ont
dit "lil n'y a pas de trace de
complicité".
Il y a pas de trace de complicité. dans
le génocide.
Il y a Oui, bien sûr. C'était ça
l'accusation d'avant.
Je peux vous poser une question ?
Et laissez-moi finir. Il il y a pas de
trace de complicité et il y a il y a
rien à dire sur Turquoise.
Accessoirement, il y a rien à dire sur
moi en tant que secrétaire général. Moi,
je m'en remettais ce qui était fait qui
me paraissait bien. Arrêter la guerre
civile, imposer le compromis politique
et cetera. Depuis le rapport du clair,
donc fin mars, il y a une campagne qui
est menée par beaucoup pas beaucoup de
gens en fait si 10 à 12 personnes
consistant à dire
la France n'est pas complice mais elle
est responsable quand même
notamment le président DCler d'ailleurs
la France est responsable
voilà et donc il y a les deux thèses
évidemment moi je suis pas d'accord sur
la deuxième thèse voyez
donc c'est une affaire qui va je pense
que la normalisation
avec le Rwanda voulue par le président
Macron est tout à fait compréhensible et
qu'elle se développera
Mais je pense que la la discussion
historique, on va dire se continue
continuera parce qu'il y aura d'autres
rapports après le rapport du clair. Il y
a d'ailleurs déjà puisque vous êtes un
un être numérique, vous devez voir les
rapports qui circulent. Il y a déjà 10 à
12 rapports qui décortiquent le rapport
du clair.
Hier, j'avais des notes confidentielles
défenses en main.
Oui, on a des milliers, vous savez tout
le temps.
Oui, on a peut-être pas lu les bons
alors.
Non, pourquoi ? À quel moment ? J'ai eu
des notes confidentielles défense en
main. J'ai eu des expertises
balistiques.
De quel moment ?
Sur le missile ?
Ah mais je vous ai dit, moi j'ai pas
j'ai pas d'avis sur l'avion. D'accord.
Et dans les deux cas,
où sont les boîtes noires ?
Dans les deux cas, c'est honorable pour
la France.
Où sont les boîtes noires ?
Dans les deux cas, c'est honorable pour
la France. Là, il y a pas d'enjeu de la
France dans l'affaire de l'avion.
D'accord. Où sont les boîtes noires ?
J'en sais rien moi.
Qui aurait pu récupérer les boîtes
noires ?
J'ai j'ai vu un télégramme diplomatique
à noté par votre main
concernant
l'arrêt des génocidaires en zone tampon
humanitaire rien à voir
où je vois où je vois des militaires où
je vois des militaires demander demander
à Paris je vous répondissoi terminer
laissez
où je vois des militaires demander à
Paris
on les attrape
et c'est à noter en marge
Ce n'est pas ce qui a été dit dans le
bureau du ministre du du premier
ministre.
Alors, je répondre sur ce point mais ça
n'a rien à voir avec les missile ça.
Non, non, c'est la conséquence.
D'accord.
Non, c'est pas la conséquence. L'affaire
des missiles, encore une fois, j'ai pas
J'en sais rien. Je ne sais pas qui a
abattu l'avion. Je ne sais pas.
Et faites attention quand vous regardez
des notes que certains extraits de
milliers de notes, il faut pas regarder
des notes qui circulent, qui défendent
toutes les positions. Faut regarder la
décision prise après. C'est vrai de
toutes les notes diplomatiques ou
autres. Alors donc sur l'avion, j'en
sais rien. On sera peut-être un jour. Je
rappelais donc qu'il y a des proches de
Kagamé qui ont expliqué avec détail
pourquoi c'était eux. C'est peut-être
pas eux mais dans les deux cas
extrémistes Touti ou tout il voulait
disons casser la politique de compromis.
Nous nous étions réjouis de voir
triompher à Rouchin puisque c'était le
but de l'intervention. L'intervention de
90 ne conduit pas au génocide, elle
conduit aux accords d'Arouchain en 93.
Alors après quand les massacres et le
génocide commencent à Paris, Mitteran
Baladure Léotard Jupeté discutent.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ? On est
parti.
Tout seul où il y a des conseillers
militaires où il y a des gens des
services de renseignement qui discutent
avec eux. Non mais comment dire
comment ça se passe ce type de
discussion ? urigants, ils ont les
travaux, les notes de tout le monde, de
tous les spécialistes. Il faut bien des
décideurs quand même. Alors donc il
décident et la question est de savoir
puisque on est parti en fait, il y a
juste une opération très rapide pour
évacuer des gens comme il y a dans tous
les drames les PC une opération à
Marilis quelques jours, ils ont sauvé je
crois 1500 personnes, moitié randé tout
et tout et moitié étranger. Et après la
vraie question qui se pose à Paris à
l'époque, c'est est-ce qu'il faut
revenir ? Alors l'armée n'est pas
favorable, c'est très compliqué, c'est
très long. L'armée qu'on présente comme
ami des Houtou, c'est complètement
débile. Ils sont pas du tout favorables.
Jupable parce qu'ils disent c'est un
génocide, ça devient un génocide, c'est
atroce, il faut revenir. Mit est plutôt
de ce côté-là.
La DGSE alter alertait alert.
La DGE n'a pas de bureau au Rwanda.
On n'est pas obligé d'avoir des bureaux.
On n'est pas obligé d'avoir des bureaux
pour faire remonter de l'information
naturellement mais d'ailleurs elle
remontait très bien et si la France
n'avait pas été consciente de cette
question elle se serait pas posé la
question de revenir pourquelle elle
reviendrait si elle était pas consciente
il y a pas besoin de note de la DGSE. Je
rappelle que le patron de la DGSE faut
compléter votre information parce que
devant la commission qui laisse le
patron expliqué qu'il n'y ait pas de
bureau au Rwanda. Oui oui et vous az
parlé de la DGSE donc je vous réponds.
Il n'avait pas de bureau au Rwanda. Il
travaillait sur la base d'information
venue de l'Ouanda ou de Belgique. Il y a
pas de bureau. Ça veut pas dire que ce
soit faux, mais il y a pas besoin de ça
pour savoir que ça tourne à l'horreur.
Et comme ça tourne à l'horreur, donc il
y a une discussion à Paris et Miton et
Baladur disons se mettent d'accord entre
eux en disant "Tu es tellement atroce
qu'il faut revenir mais on va revenir
avec un mandat des Nations Unies pour
que ce soit incontestable."
Donc, on demande à New York un mandat
des Nations- Unies et malheureusement le
mandat des Nations- Unies ne sera obtenu
que le 22 juin si je me trompe pas
parce que les Américains veulent pas
faire une opération, ils veulent pas
qu'on parle de génocide. D'abord,
des agents dans la base de CONAB,
le
Kabé
quoi ?
Des agents de la DGSE stationnés sur
cette base là.
Oui. Oui. Mais regardez ce que dit
Zilerzan à ce sujet. Alors donc les
Américains ne veulent pas revenir en
Afrique
parce que le beau génocide entraîne les
obligations. Ils ont eu des marines
s'assassinent en Somalie si je me trompe
pas et donc il y a un mandat pour faire
l'opération turquoise. Mais l'opération
turquoise n'est obtenue du conseil de
sécurité qu'à condition je suis en train
de répondre à la question qui m' posée
sur la notation hein.
Ne l'opération turquoise est une
opération humanitaire
sans interposition. Donc il faut
absolument pas être au contact du FPR,
ni tout de rien. Donc il faut des eau de
neutre entre les deux. Il y a évidemment
pas d'arrestation.
Dans aucune opération de rétablissement
de maintien de la paix de l'ONU, il n'y
a des arrestations.
Tous les Étatsmembres de l'ONU sont liés
par la convention 1948 sur le génocide
qui oblige tout le monde à prévenir et à
réprimer le crime de génocide.
Et vous m'interrogez en tant que courant
là.
Vous vous me laissez expliquer ou vous
défendez une thèse.
Je défends pas de thèse.
Si vous défendez une thèse là,
quelle est ma thèse ?
Mais la thèse, vous desextrayez d'un
océan de document de trois choses qui
qui essaient de contredire ce que
j'essaie de vous dire. Fait l'avocat du
diable.
Ah d'accord,
mais au moins c'est plus net comme ça.
Avocat du diable. Alors donc je vous
réponds sur la la question des
militaires.
Donc l'opération turquoise à Lieu, ils
se mettent au Congo parce qu'il faut pas
en République démocratique du Congo
et comme arrivent des ordres de gens,
ils ont sauvé quand même on pense 20 à
30000 personnes et dans l'ensemble il y
a sans doute des génocidaires.
C'est pas évident à déterminer. Je vous
signale que non le tribunal d'Aroucha,
le vrai tribunal et en place après dans
beaucoup de cas, ils n'arriveront pas à
déterminer l'intention génocidaire. Même
le tribunal international mis en place
après alors des militaires qui sont
confrontés à des mouvements de
population, qu'est-ce qu'ils font ?
Naturellement,
il ils disent qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
D'où la réunion à Matignon,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Il y a peut-être
des gars génocidaires dans le paquet.
C'est tout à fait possible.
Non, il demande, c'est une opération des
Nations Unies, il y a un mandat précis,
il demande ce qu'ils peuvent faire et la
réunion à Maton
à laquelle je vais moi pour tenir
informer le président, c'est pas une
réunion à l'Élysée, hein, c'est une
réunion à Maton, donc autour du premier
ministre avec Alain Jupé, Léotard et
cetera et cetera. Ils disent "Bah nous,
on ne peut que demander à New York à
l'opération des maintiens de la paix si
on peut changer le mandat. Qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire ?" il demande et il y a
pas de réponse de New York où la réponse
c'est qu'on peut pas changer le mandat.
Donc il y a aucune initiative française
par rapport à ça. La France est tenue.
J'en viens à la note.
Comme il y a une dépêche le jour même,
j'ai redécouvert ça des années après
parce que j'avais aucun souvenir de de
ça. Une dépêche qui annonce qu'on va
arrêter parce que certains voudraient
qu'on arrête les génocidaires. Si on
pouvait être sûr que c'est eux. En plus
il y a pas marqué génocidaire, c'est pas
évident. Donc une dépêche une dépêche,
il y a une dépêche qui annonce
l'arrestation et moi je me borne à noter
pour le président que c'est pas la
décision prise à Maton puisque la
décision c'est de demander à New York.
Donc il y a pas de décision prise
d'arrestation. Point. Il y a aucune
initiative de l'Élysée, ni du président,
ni des conseillers, ni même du
gouvernement. Et Alain Jupé demande à
son conseiller Bernardier
après de donner cette réponse et on
attend la réponse de New York. La
réponse de New York, c'est que le
conseil de sécurité ne veut pas bouger.
Et d'ailleurs, vous remarquerez que si
vous étudiez les autres opérations de
l'ONU dans des domaines un peu
sensibles, il y a jamais d'arrestation.
Il peut y avoir la création d'un
tribunal et d'ailleurs la France va
évidemment voter pour la création du
tribunal d'Aoucha hein après.
Alors le gouvernement intermédiaire 13
membres sont identifiés et localisés à
Sion Gougou. Pas de doute sur leur rôle.
L'ambassadeur Yannick Gérard demande
d'arrêter ses membres du gouvernement
génocidé.
Et donc c'est le résultat, c'est
pourquoi il y a une réunion à Maton.
Mais j'ai déjà répondu.
Est-ce que vous comprenez quand quand
moi je lis ça,
donne l'impression qu'on a protégé la
fuite des génocidaires.
Pourquoi vous pensez ça ?
Parce qu'on aurait pu les choper même si
on avait pas le mandat. Vous voyez
quelqu'un dans la rue se faire tabasser
dans la rue,
vous faites quoi ? Vous appelez la
police, vous attendez qu'on vous donne
mandat de le choper, vous faites quoi ?
On est on est une armée, d'accord ? On
identifie les gars qui ont trucidé des
toutsi qui ont planifié un génocide.
Mais ce génocide, laissez-moi terminer,
laissez-moi terminer.
D'après ce que j'ai en tête, les
militaires n'étaient pas devant les
actes de génocide. Mais ils les ont vu.
Non non non, c'est pas ça.
Ils ont vu les cadavres partout les
mecs. Je suis désolé mais
à la machette dans le livre
pour lequel vous m'avez invité, il y a
250 entrées.
Oui
hein. Je vois vous êtes en relation avec
des gens qui vous ont préparé les
questions. Je les connais. Je suis en
train de lire mes
Je connais les questions, je connais les
réponses et si vous voulez bien après
les émissions, je vous enverrai une
liste de 20 25 articles ou livres
français, camerounais, congolais, belge,
américain, canadien et cetera qui disent
exactement le contraire dont aucun ne
s'en prend à la France.
Alors mais pourquoi ? Pourquoi
pourquoi le rapport du Cler qui est un
rapport hostile,
pourquoi le rapport du Cler a conclu
qu'il y avait rien à dire sur Turquoise
?
le rapport du clair qui est partie d'un
a priori hostile dont les conclusions
d'ailleurs sont tout à fait différentes
des chapitres d'analyse des pièces. Donc
j'appelle simplement et je le dis aux
gens qui qui nous écoutent compris aux
gens qui sont disons bouleversés par la
question je comprends c'est un génocide
il y a quand même 20 25 articles ou
livres dans le monde.
Le seul pays où on accède pas c'est en
France qui raconte l'histoire du
génocide qui est pas contesté autrement.
Autrement donc la focalisation sur une
responsabilité française, moi je la
conteste. Voilà.
Alors est contesté d'abord à cause
d'Aucha et puis après je la conteste en
pensant que c'est le seul pays qui a qui
a tenté d'atténuer les horaires. Voilà.
Alors pourquoi en France il se passe ça
? Pourquoi ? Par exemple ce matin, je
lis le testament de Rocard sur sur le
Rwanda dans Libération
avec il dit
"On a identifié les gens, c'est un
massacre, j'ai été sur place, j'ai
discuté avec au moins 50 personnes, je
vous fais je vous transmets mes
questions, il y a un problème."
Il faudrait redonner les dates, mais
c'est pe ça aurait été mieux de dire aux
gens que vous vouliez faire une émission
sur ce sujet.
Mais on a fait pas que ça sur ce sujet.
en train de la faire sur ce sujet parce
que je serais venu, je vous avais envoyé
avant d'ailleurs la les articles, les
livres qui sont très intéressants, les
autres sources et vous êtes toujours
avec les mêmes sources là.
Si c'est toujours les mêmes sources,
c'est les mêmes arguments qu'on connaît
bien depuis le rapport Miau, c'est les
mêmes, ça tourne depuis le début. Alors
ça, il faut retrouver les dates si vous
voulez parce que moi j'ai rappelé tout à
l'heure que l'engagement de la France de
conduit aux accords d'Arouchain en 93.
Sinon, il y aurait eu des massacres
avant, hein. Et on tout le monde était
très content en 93 parce qu'on pensait
qu'on avait
qu'on avait réglé la chose par un
compromis et s'il y avait eu pas les
accusations sans arrêt sans arrêt
répéter y compris les vôtres, on
pourrait traiter la on pourrait traiter
la vraie question, c'est de savoir
est-ce qu'il fallait est-ce qu'il
fallait intervenir en 90 ?
Est-ce qu'il fallait pas malheureusement
laisser la guerre civile se dérouler
sans qu'on y puisse rien ? Et il y a une
autre question assez compliquée, c'est
qu'il fallait pas essayer après à
Rouchin de mettre en place une force
internationale pour disons pour la mise
en place des des accords voyen. Bon mais
ça n'a pas été le cas. Le FPR ne voulait
pas que la France reste, on est parti.
une for des Nations Unie qui s'est
décomposé en avril avril 94 notamment
parce que les Belges ont retiré tous
leurs contingents.
Donc moi je trouve que les accusations
après par rapport au seul pays au seul
pays qui a dit on est on est disposé
faire une opération humanitaire il y
avait des contingents africains pour
être honnête hein. Il y avait des
Sénégalais d'autres l'opération
turquoise où même le rapport du clair
hostile n'a rien trouvé à redire. Donc
en fait vous revenez sur le rapport du
clair là, vous le vous le trouvez pas
assez dur si je comprends bien.
On a on a lu le le
qu'est-ce que vous pensez qu'est-ce que
vous pensez quand médiia part vous étrie
?
Ben je sais pas, j'écoute pas, je
regarde pas spécialement médiia par
et je veux pas m'enfermer dans le sujet
puisque on va laisser les gens et moi je
suis pas d'accord avec cette thèse. Je
vous donne l'opportunité d'y répondre.
Non, je suis pas venu pour ça et on a
déjà beaucoup parlé
et malheureusement que j'ai pas pensé
que vous dévelopz ça à ce point. Je suis
pas venu avec la liste des mais il y a
des
quel bouquin il faut lire ? Quel bouquin
il faut lire sur le Rwanda pour
comprendre la situation ? Alors
comprendre, je sais pas, c'est très
compliqué mais d'abord il y a un que
sège. Il y a un que sège sur le génocide
des rédigé par un grand professeur belge
qui s'appelle monsieur Rinstins
et qui était expert au tribunal
d'Aroucha. Mais évidemment les gens dont
nous parlons ne l'aiment pas qui
n'attaquent pas la France.
Qui sont ces gens-là ? Mais il y a des
des gens, il y a des ONG par exle
l'organisation survie qui attaque la
France mais depuis avant la F du Rwanda,
ils ont toujours attaqué la C'est eux
qui ont d'ailleurs euh organisé le
voyage de Rocard. Ils ont toujours euh
attaqué la France sur la politique
française en Afrique en général. Après
il y a
c'est quoi cette ONG ? C'est une ONG
très ancienne euh créée par quelqu'un
qui est décédé maintenant mais dont le
nom va me revenir qui a toujours
condamné en gros la politique française
en Afrique, pas uniquement les
interventions, disons la l'exploitation
de l'Afrique, le colonialisme, c'est
Verschave, je crois, je crois que
c'était le le fondateur, hein, mais
c'est très ancien, c'est même avant
Mitteran et c'est avant le Rwanda. Alors
donc, il y a il y a un que moi je trouve
honnête.
Il y a des enquêtes d'une canadienne qui
s'appelle Judy R
qui est une ancienne de RFI qui a eu des
prix au Canada et au Pays-Bas.
C'est c'est la dame qui dit qu'il y
avait des Touts qui s'étaient infiltrés
dans les checkpoints des Houtou et ainsi
de suite. C'est ça.
Elle est pas la seule à dire ça. Elle a
elle a donné beaucoup d'interviews en
Afrique du Sud parce que les
Sud-Africains ne croient ça
tient pas la route ça.
Les Sud-Africains ne croient pas du tout
la thèse de Kigali en général. Les
Congolais encore moins mais pour
d'autres raisons. Les africains sont pas
unanimes par rapport à ça. Et je dis R a
décrit deux choses. D'abord les certains
massacres des troubles du FPR quand ils
attaquent en 9091 et puis d'autre part
ce qui s'est passé au Congo après voyez
après en après 94 96 80 ça elle a écrit
ce qu'on ce qu' a décrit le rapport des
nations génies là-dessus. Elle est elle
a eu accès aux sources des Nations Unies
dit sur le rapport du mapping qui est
pas une personne, c'est une procédure le
rapport mapping qui a décrit les
massacres dans le Kivou.
Après vous avez des auteurs africains
comme le franco-camerounais Onana qui a
travaillé sur l'opération turquoise.
Vous avez un grand spécialiste l'Afrique
des Grand Lac qui s'appelle monsieur
Guichawa. Enfin, il y en a un certain
nombre et puis après, il y a beaucoup de
d'articles de différents pays. Mais si
vous vouliez vraiment comparer les les
deux thèses, vous avez les les thèses ou
avec les messages que vous êtes en train
de lire qui sont dans un sens et vous
avez pas mal d'autres livres qui
méritent d'être lu. Alors évidemment les
autres livres en général,
je lis les messages de la communauté.
D'accord, mais j'ai je les reconnais. Et
donc vous avez les autres thèses qui
malheureusement
sont très peuus en France parce qu'il y
a une campagne organisée pour dire que
ce sont des livres négationnistes.
Qui qui organise cette campagne selon
vous ?
Bah il y a eu pendant longtemps à Kigali
un bureau spécialisé dans la chivie des
opinions étrangères notamment belge
notamment française américaine et
cetera. Et alors, il y a une tension en
ce moment parce que la la presse
anglo-saxonne qui a été très très
favorable à Kagamé depuis le début a
quand même pas mal changé depuis
quelques temps et par exemple Z
économiste aujourd'hui qui une référence
dit c'est une dictature une dictature et
ce qui est dit sur les résultats
économiques du Rwanda c'est largement
trafiqué bon il y a eu pas mal de je
veux signaler que madame Judy R qui est
très attaquée précisément parce que ce
qu'elle dit est quand même très embêtant
Elle a fait de grands articles en
Afrique du Sud. Les Sud-Africains sont
assez d'accord avec elle. Au Congo, il y
a un autre débat qui concerne les
Congolais dont moi je me suis jamais
mêlé. Les Français non plus d'ailleurs.
Les Congolais pensent que il y a eu
quand même des massacres énormes au
Kivou. Et le rapport mapping dit on peut
se poser la question d'un génocide au
Congo mais c'est pas mon point de vue.
J'ai pas d'expertise là-dessus.
Vous parlez quoi du Kivou là ?
Je parle de l'est du Congo. Oui du
Kivou. Et c'est ce que et le prix Nobel
de la paix, le docteur Mouegé qui est
cet homme extraordinaire qui qui opère,
qui répare les femmes violées,
violentées, blessé et cetera, lui il
demande un tribunal pénal international
pour le Congo, pour le Congo, pas pour
le jeunesse de rwandais qui est pas
contesté, voyez. Et d'ailleurs le
président Kagamé qui était de passage à
Paris il y a quelques jours a attaqué le
prix Nobel de la paix dans son interview
au monde. Donc il y a une dimension
grosse bagarre entre africains.
Là ce dont ce dont je viens de parler
c'est pas une question pardon
franco-wandaise. Voyez c'est un débat
entre africains et moi j'ai pas
d'éléments d'appréciation. Je me borne à
intervenir dans le débat en essayant de
rappeler quelles ont été les intentions
de la France de 90 à 93.
Question internet. Le rôle du ministre
des affaires étrangères est-il vraiment
de vendre des armes aux autres pays ?
Est-ce qu'on a vendu des armes pendant
le génocide ?
Non. Et non, même le rapport du CLI dit
que non.
Je suis étonné par vos questions parce
que dans vos questions, il y a des
questions qui reviennent sur le rapport
du cl qui qui est très sévère même si la
conclusion n'a rien à voir avec la les
chapitres d'analyse dans le rapport du
clair pour ce je pense pas que les gens
l'élu, il fait je crois 1000 pages hein.
Alors donc c'est la commission
d'historien mis en place par le
président Macron qui a ouvert toutes les
archives et qui ont tout regardé. Alors,
il y a six chapitres que je trouve moi
assez objectif de présentation des
archives. Il y a un chapitre
d'interprétation que je trouve moi
totalement biaisé, partisan et cetera,
enfin d'autres gens. Sur chacun des
points, sur chacun des points, ils ne
tiennent pas compte par exemple du fait
que l'engagement de la France a abouti
aux accords d'Arouchain.
Le compromis très favorable. Aroucha en
août 93,
il y a pas que nous, il y a tous les
autres. On a un élément nous darou, on
donne au touti 40 % de l'armée 40 % de
l'armée future alors qui représente 12 à
13 % de la population. Donc c'est pas un
accord pour les outous pour écraser de
leur matoritaire les toutci. Voyez donc
le rapport du clair est rempli de rempli
de trucs comme ça. Bon et après il y a
la conclusion qui est encore différente
mais il y a deux personnes de la
commission qui se sont retirées avant
parce qu'ils n'ont pas obtenu que les
conclusions soient débattues
collectivement. Après, il y a les
interviews du président DCler en plus du
rapport qui vont plus loin qui demandent
des excuses. Mais on sait pas très bien
de quoi il faut s'excuser parce que
est-ce qu' la France va s'excuser d'être
intervenu en 90 ? On pourrait en
discuter de ce point, mais c'était pour
bloquer la guerre civile, imposer le
compromis. Bon, est-ce qu'il faut
s'excuser d'avoir fait turquoise ? Mais
même le rapport du clé n'a rien trouvé à
critiquer à turquoise. C'est une
opération des Nations Unies. Alors, très
enfermée, humanitaire mais pas
interposition ni arrestation. Bon, je
vois pas très bien. Donc le
travail va continuer sur le l'aspect
historique. Je reviens ce que j'ai dit
au début parce que vous m'avez titillé.
C'est votre jeu, c'est normal.
Encore, ça n'était que l'apéritif.
Bon et donc j'ai répondu, je pense que
le travail historique va continuer et
que d'une façon ou d'une autre, les
autres pays protagonistes vont être
obligés de de suivre l'exemple de la
France, on va dire.
Alors,
qui a beaucoup beaucoup ouvert.
Est-ce que est-ce que on a vendu des
armes pendant le génocide ? Et est-ce
qu'on a vendu des armes au génocidair ?
Et bien sûr que non. Le rapport du clair
dit que non.
D'accord. Est-ce qu'on a fermé ?
Il y a une il y a une coopération
militaire avant jusqu'aux accords
Naroucha.
Est-ce qu'on a fermé les yeux quand on
avait la capacité d'attraper des
génocidaires ?
J'ai déjà répondu que les militaires ont
demandé, ce qui est très bien de leur
part, que le gouvernement a vu qu'il
était tenu par le le mandat, ils ont
demandé à New York.
Honnêtement, je sais pas ce qu'ils
auraient fait si le si à New York le
département du maintien de la paix
dirigé à l'époque par monsieur Cofian
avait dit faut essayer d'attraper les
génocidaires.
C'est pas évident. Même le tribunal
d'Aroucha qui a fait un travail
magnifique les années après et que la
France avait aidé à constituer a eu le
plus grand mal. On a on a Rocard qui
dans son testament sur le le Rwanda dit
"Quel a été le rôle exact des
conseillers militaires français
lors de l'opération Norrois ?"
Nor
roi c'est avant à Rouchasse.
C'est quoi l'opération de Norrois ?
Et ben, c'est ce que j'ai rappelé en
disant qu'en 80
en 90 donc Mitan a décidé de bloquer la
guerre civile par une intervention,
c'est Norrois. Il y a d'ailleurs un
livre qui est à mon avis beaucoup plus
intéressant que la que ce que dit Recard
là qui est en gros la disons les
positions de l'ONG de l'époque qui
organisé sa visite, c'est le livre du
général de l'or qui a commandé Norwai et
qui explique ce qu'ils ont fait, ce
qu'ils ont fait, ce qu'ils ont pas fait
et il y a pas eu de d'affrontement
direct noroi et des troupes du FPR.
Voyez donc leur rôle c'était d'être en
soutien à l'armée rwandaise face à
l'attaque du FPR et de l'Ouganda. Ça
c'est le volet militaire.
Est-ce que les
Mais en général, on oublie le volet
politico-diplomatique,
c'est-à-dire puisqu'on est là et qu'on
vous protège, vous devez partager le
pouvoir. Et plus les pressions de la
France étaient insistantes et plus les
outou les plus extrémistes ont refusé
ça. Ils sont sortis du gouvernement. Il
y a eu plusieurs remanements. Donc
autour du président Abbiana, il y avait
des gens qui se régnaient à la
politique, à la demande de la France. Il
faut partager le pouvoir. Les autres
disaient non, on veut pas partager le
pouvoir. Les tout ils vont revenir. Ils
vont rétablir l'exploitation d'avant.
Ils vont vendre le ils vont reprendre le
bétail, la terre et cetera. Donc il faut
les bloquer, voir les exterminer. Et
vous avez le début, vous observez le
début de la du délire génocidaire du
côté Outou. Mais c'est pas le président,
c'est le système Outou qui refuse le
compromis. Il y a pas de raison qu'on
partage le pouvoir avec ces gens. Ils
sont 12 %, ils viennent de l'Ouanda et
nous on est 85 % et la France dit non,
désolé, la seule façon de d'éviter le
pire, c'est d'imposer un compromis. Et
on croyait, je le répète, avoir réussi à
Roucha. Donc tout ce qui est conseillé,
c'est avant
au moment d'Aroucha, donc KAGAM demande
que la France parte. C'est là où
malheureusement, il aurait fallu une
énorme force africaine ou internationale
pour imposer l'accord. Il reste une
trentaine de conseillers français après,
c'est tout.
Est-ce que la France a fait des appuis
feu pour protéger les houtou ?
J'en sais rien. Mais pendant pendant les
gos la France est pas là. Si c'est
avant, même réponse.
Mais j'aimerais bien on est compte qu'il
y a 249 entrées dans le dictionnaire
géopolitique sur d'autres sujets. Il y a
Jean Giscan, il y a Biden, il y a et
cetera et cetera. Donc dans les conflits
la période 9080
93 donc avant Roucha la France est en en
soutien c'est l'opération n roi dirigée
par le général de l'or. Voilà et ils ont
face à eux le FPR
et madame Jidy R dans ses enquêtes dit
que le FPR a massacré des cadres ou tout
en avance. Ça c'est ce que c'est ce
qu'on dit d'ailleurs les juges espagnols
il y a une dizaine d'années parce qu'il
y a des malheureux espagnols qui étaient
dans des ONG à cet endroit qui ont été
tués dans les batailles FPR et cetera.
Donc il y a une longue procédure
judiciaire en Espagne et la plus haute
autorité espagnole avait analysé mais
jamais les médias français l'ont repris
ça comment le le FPR avait déstabilisé
le Rwanda pour justifier son
intervention parce qu'au début il y a
pas de risque de génocide au début ils
interviennent pas pour arrêter le
génocide voyez faut pas confondre 90 93
et 94 une grande partie du débat est
quand même
après le 6è avril c'est ça 94
oui l'avion c'est en 94 Le 6 avril.
Le 6 avril. Oui.
Dans les 24h, les 48h juste après le
l'avion du président abattu,
tout a été très vite. Est-ce que ça
révèle d'une planification de longue
date de ce génocide des toutsi parlout
tout ?
Dans le livre du général de l'or, moi
qui m'a appris plein de choses, il dit
que il y a une énorme confusion
de part et d'autre.
Mais ça paraît quand même
spontané un peu partout. Ça se fait à
coup de machette
pour l'essentiel. Donc le débat sur les
armes est un petit peu hors sujet et je
vous rappelle que le tribunal d'Arouchin
après a eu beaucoup de mal à déterminer
la préparation, l'organisation.
Mais ce qu'il y a de ce qui est sûr
c'est que enfin ce qui est sûr jeis pas
dire ça parce que j'en sais rien en fait
mais je pense qu'au fur et à mesure des
avancées de Kagamé 90 91 92 il y a un
état d'esprit très très violent donc
jusqu'à un esprit génocidaire qui se
répand dans tout le système ou tout sans
même que ce soit organisé
la terreur de voir se rétablir le régime
d'avant 62 et donc ça c'est très diffus
il y a même pas besoin joint que je sois
organisé pour que ce soit un génocide en
fait, vous voyez.
Non mais pour que ça aille aussi vite,
c'est forcément qu'il y avait des des
des gens qui ont pensé durer de mois
hein.
Aller chercher certains ministres, aller
chercher certains leaders tout de suite,
ça veut dire qu'il y avait des listes
quand même.
Les pas le président Abirana lui-même
hein qui est mort dans l'attentat.
D'ailleurs, s'ils l'ont tué, si on pense
que c'est lesouous ils l'ont tué, c'est
parce que il lui reprochait d'accepter
les pressions de la France pour le
compromis.
Même chose dans l'autre sens. C'était
pas une histoire qu'il y avait deux
généraux qui allaient perdre leur titre
de général donc ils allaient pas perdre
leur rente. Non non non c'était Attendez
on parle d'un génocide c'est bien
entendu.
Non mais c'est pas lié à d'histoire de
généraux. Non je pense qu'il y a une une
grande partie des Houtou qui n'acceptait
pas les accords d'Aroucha qui voulaient
rien lâcher et une partie du FPR qui
voulait tout prendre. Voilà
comment on a
la vraie erreur pour moi, toutes vos
questions se répètent mais la vraie
question pour moi qui est l'incidente
c'est que si n'avait pas eu le souvenir
des massacre atroces de 62 et s'il
n'avait pas pris la décision en 90 de
tenter de bloquer la guerre civile s'il
avait dit c'est épouvantable mais bon on
y peut rien c'est loin c'était une
colonie belge c'est pas nous et cetera
et cetera, je pense qu'on lui aurait
reproché cruellement la non intervention
alors évidemment en parlait peut-être
pas aujourd'hui la même formie des
massacres atroces peut-être un génocide
en 90 ou 91.
Ça c'est une question qui est jamais
posée mais même moi qui essaie d'être le
plus le plus honnête et le plus
convaincant sur l'héritage mitéran par
rapport à ça, je considère que la
question se pose est-ce qu'il fallait
vraiment en 90 essayer de d'enrayer le
processus ? L'autre question compliquée,
mais j'en ai parlé, c'est est-ce qu'il
fallait pas après à Roucha, même si
Kagamé exigeait qu'on parte parce qu'il
avait évidemment d'autres projets pour
la suite, est-ce qu'il fallait pas
essayer
que les Africains, le Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU, mette en place un
système ? Voyez ? Et ça c'est pas une
question franco-française.
C'est une question globale ça.
La question que je me pose c'est on est
au 20e siècle c'estàd il y a pas si
longtemps que ça.
En 100 jours, il y a un million de
morts.
Mais le Cambodge c'est pas tellement
vieux. C'est au Cambodge
c'est au 20e siècle aussi. C'est à la
fin du 20e siècle.
Donc j'ai peur que le siècles ne
changent rien.
Donc il y a pas si longtemps que ça
100 jours, 1 million de morts
on parle de 2 millions de morts, on
parle de quasiment 30 % de la
population. Oui, c'est très très
rapidement. horrible à la machette
planifié quand les autorités euh
radicalisé ou tout
balance
c'est pas c'est pas le président ça
balance balance à la population
aller régler leur compte au touti
100 jours et c'est des milliers et des
milliers et des milliers de morts par
jour quand l'armée française
va dans les collines Rappelez-moi les
collines de
J'ai un trou de mémoire.
Non mais la France n'est pas là à ce
moment-là.
Il y a il y a la France qui
la France trouve 3000 3000 tout planqués
dans la montagne.
On attendait
les touts sortent de la montagne en
disant aidez-nous aidez-nous aidez-nous.
On va se faire trucider. On se fait
trucider. On se fait trucider. Les
Français disent on va revenir dans 3
jours.
Non mais excusez-moi, c'est là où votre
vos interrogations sont pas à la hauteur
de la réputation de votre site parce que
vous on en a parlé déjà cinq fois. Vous
remélangez les dates.
Remélang me parlez de la la fin de
l'opération turquoise.
Quand les génocide commence et se se
développe pendant des semaines de façon
atroce. C'est en avril-mai.
La France n'est pas là en avril mai. La
France n'obtient l'accord du conseil de
sécurité pour revenir que le 22 juin.
C'est pas nous qui avons retardé la
date. Il y a pas que la France, il y a
des contingents africains. Et la
question horrible dont vous parlez des
tirs assemblés sur des collines qui
appellent à l'aide et la la l'opération
turquoise, son mandat street c'est
d'être au Congo, pas dans le Rwanda. Et
le général la Fourcade a expliqué 36
fois qu'il dirigeait le l'opération 36
fois que ils avaient pas les moyens
d'aller au Rwanda. Normalement, ils
avaient pas le droit. Fallait rassembler
des moyens logistiques. La Fourcade, il
est il est torturé par cette question.
On lui pose sans arrêt. Il a déjà
répondu 36 fois. Vous n'avez pas les
moyens d'aller les sauver. Ils sont
arrivés trop tard. Ils en ont sauvé
peut-être que Mais pourquoi ? Attendez,
je comprends pas pourquoi vous me posez
des questions auxquelles il a été
répondu 36 fois mais pas citer une seule
fois les réponses de la fourcade mais
pas cité une seule fois les réponses à
toutes les questions qui ont été mises
en avant et le rapport du clc lui-même
qui était obsédé par la recherche d'une
culpabilité française n'a pas trouvé
disait rien sur turquoise. Vous me
parlez de turquoise. Si c'était s s'il y
avait des traces de ça, ce serait dans
le rapport du clair. Vous êtes vous êtes
disons vous faites de la surenchère sur
le rapport du claire. J'essaie d'avoir
de vos réponses.
Non mais et le rapport du clair, même si
moi je conteste le chapitre
d'interprétation et les conclusions, je
note que même dans la partie disons
sévère et critique, il y a pas ça sur
turquoise. des accusations qui
circulaient depuis des années des années
depuis le rapport Miau fait par les
Randés en donc 2008 pour se protéger des
accusations de Bruèr mais qui n'ont même
pas été retenu par le rapport du Cler
qui est un rapport à charge.
Donc je vois bien.
Est-ce que est-ce queà votre avis il y
aura un rapport à décharg ?
Bah il y a tous les livres que je vous
ai cité mais qui ont comme point commun
de pas tellement parler de la France.
Il considère évidemment pas que le il y
a qu'en France qu'on peut considérer que
la France soit coupable au responsable.
C'est un truc purement mau français.
Donc aucun des autres livres n'est sur
cette ligne, mais c'est pas un rapport à
déchargge non plus parce que les autres
livres que j'ai cité rapidement, j'ai
cité quatre auteurs mais il y en a
beaucoup plus en réalité se sont
intéressés au parcours de Kagamé qui est
exceptionnel
qui est qui est une sorte de ligne qui
est incroyablement douée à partir de
l'Ouganda et toute la suite y compris
toute l'opération au Congo. Je parle pas
tellement du Kivou, je parle de la mamie
sur le pouvoir à Kinshasa. Donc les
autres livres que ce soit Gisha Chawa,
Onana, Judy Rever, restin à ses et
compagnie, ils ont pas spécialement fait
un livre pour dire les accusations
contre la France sont injustes. Ils
l'ont dit dans des colloques en disant
c'est totalement débile mais ils sont
intéressés à autre chose. L'histoire de
l'Afrique centrale. Qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé dans cette région malheureuse du
monde ? Vous savez, au cœur des
ténèbres, c'est ça le roman, hein, ce
qui s'est passé en Ouanda, ce qui s'est
passé au Rwanda, ce qui s'est passé,
j'ai cité les massacres de 62, mais il y
en a eu d'autres
contre les TSI en général, il y a eu les
massacres au Burundi en général dans
l'autre sens. Il y a le Congo, il y a
tout ça. Donc les autres livres, ils
remettent dans le contexte et je pense
que ceux qui se contentent pas
d'accusation, disons un peu de slogan,
peuvent se plonger dans un de ses
livres. J'en ai cité 34.
Question internet.
Pendant pendant le génocide, est-ce que
les satellites français ont pris ils ont
pris des image pas d'image. Comment ça
se passait la remontée d'information ?
Et j'ai pas compris la question.
Pendant le génocide, est-ce que
l'information euh du gouvernement
français se faisait par l'espace ?
C'està-dire qu'on avait des satellites
qui prenaient des photos. Est-ce que
vous avez vu des photos satellites de ce
qui se passait ? sur place. Oui, enfin
c'était des massacres humains du sol à
coup de machette. Bon, bien sûr,
mais il y a eu des grands photographes
de presse qui était là-bas. Il y en a
notamment un qui était là pour une
grande agence qui a écrit un long texte
qui qui est complètement opposé aux
accusations qui a été sur place tout le
génocides c'était atroce. Donc il y a eu
des ça me donc il défend les positions
françaises en tout cas il conteste les
accusations mais ça me fait penser qu'il
y a eu des grands photographes pour les
grandes agences mondiales hein. Mais à
quoi ils ont eu accès ? J'en sais rien
moi. Ils ont pas
À votre avis Macron demain il va dire
quoi ?
Je sais j'en sais rien.
J'en sais rien. Mais comme je l'ai dit
au début je pense qu'on peut distinguer
la normalisation. Le président Macron
veut avoir les relations les plus
normales possibles avec le Rwanda en
raison de la de la l'influence du poids
de Paul Kagané en Afrique. Même s'il a
plusieurs grands pays qui sont tout à
fait opposés à sa politique, il a quand
même une influence réelle. Et voilà.
Très bien. J'ai rien à dire de plus.
J'en sais rien. J'ai j'ai bien dissocié
depuis le début de ce long échange sur
le sujet l'aspect normalisation et
l'aspect recherche de la vérité
historique qui ne pourra se faire que
quand d'autres pays auront ouvert aussi.
Genre la Belgique, ben
j'ai fait la liste le Rwanda, le FPR, le
Rwanda, la Belgique, la Grande-Bretagne,
l'Oganda, le Israël, les Américains, le
tribunal d'Aroucha, le département des
maintiens de la paix de l'ONU et cetera
et cetera. Il y a Pourquoi il le ferait
pas ? Votre intime condition sur ce
dossier-là ? qui se l'avait demandé hein
dans un une lettre au secrétaire général
des nations juni
là non mais me choque pas j'ai été voir
deux fois moi comme ministre deux fois
je l'ai vu il a jamais posé de problème
pour me voir hein première fois j'étais
seul parce que je faisais le tour de
l'Afrique centrale que je connaissais
pas bien en fait
comment ça se prépare ce genre de voyage
et l'année suivante j'étais avec le
ministre anglais
comment ça se prépare ce genre de voyage
vous êtes accompagné d'un service de
sécurité vous êtes briefé avant
c'est les voyages En général, ça
il y a les voyages du ministre.
D'abord, on décide d'aller à tel ou tel
endroit en fonction de des urgences, des
sommets, des choses. Après, quel que
soit l'endroit du monde, vous avez des
ambassades qui ont préparé des dossiers,
ça remonte auqu d'Orsé où il y a une
direction d'Asie ou d'Afrique ou
d'Amérique ou ceci cela. Il y a un
cabinet du ministre qui mouline les
notes, qui ajoute les éléments et
finalement il y a des il y a des thèmes
mis en avant et puis on vous décrit dans
les notes le si vous connaissez pas déjà
le sujet, on vous décrit
l'interlocuteur, son parcours, les
sujets dont on va sans doute parler et
cetera. C'est c'est des belles machines.
C'est des gens les fameux diplomates là
dont vous parliez au début là en
souriant un peu. C'est quand même des
gens qui travaille énormément, très
compétent, très dévoué et qui arrivent à
faire pour un un ministre un dossier en
quelques heures sur n'importe quel sujet
dans le monde quand même. Et alors quand
on fait une tournée comme je l'avais
fait, il y avait le dossier Ronda, le
dossier Burundi, le dossier Tanzadil, le
dossier Congo Braza, Congo Kinshasa et
cetera. J'avais été voir Muséeni en
Ouganda aussi. Est-ce que est-ce que les
services des fois peuvent vous dire "Non
non, monsieur le ministre, c'est trop
dangereux d'aller vous balader là-bas ?"
C'est pas les service du qu d'ors ça
c'est la la protection. Oui. Enfin, on
m'a jamais dit ça pour l'Afrique.
Jamais dit ça pour l'Afrique.
Quand on avait plus d'ambassadeur au
Rwanda, c'était pourquoi ?
Ah, c'est parce que c'est après, c'est
parce queil y a des c'est dans la
période de tension, rapport Boger et
cetera. Rapport, rapport Miaux et
cetera. Ça aucun rapport avec l'époque
du génocide ça. Donc moi j'ai de toute
façon les dans ces voyages les services
de sécurité, les services de police, les
services tout ça, ils sont en relation
avec les services sur place. Ils savent
très bien ce qui est dangereux ou pas,
où il faut aller ou pas aller. Mais
d'ailleurs plus largement même en tant
qu'individu, vous savez bien que si vous
allez dans des pays un peu fragiles,
vous vous regardez sur le conseil aux
voyageurs qui sait.
Non, n'appréciez pas. Si si conseil aux
voyageurs
parce que c'est moi qui a donné le feu
vert pour que ça soit créé à l'époque.
Les agences de voyage ne voulaient pas
parce que ça tué le business.
Ben il disait ça, on va perdre des
voyageurs parce qu'il y a toujours des
zones à risque. Enfin, on a on a faut
dire aujourd'hui c'est un des cycles les
plus consultés de France en terme de
service public. Alors on dit aux gens
faites attention à tel ou tel endroit et
cetera. Bon, pour un pour un président
ou un ministre, ça se passe pas comme ça
parce qu'ils sont ils sont transportés
et la question se pose pas.
Tu m arrivé, j'ai des souvenirs avec
Mitéran de danger, hein,
du genre.
Bah, par exemple, quand il y avait eu le
en 83 l'attentat contre le contingent
français de la force des Nations Unies
au Liban,
il y avait l'attentat dans l'immeuble
dit le Dracard, un attentat terrible. Il
y avait eu, je crois, 80 morts.
Le président Mitteran avait estimé qu'il
fallait qu'il se rende sur place pour
montrer sa solidarité
avec l'armée, avec les victimes, les
familles, les Libanais et cetera. Bon,
donc on y va. Personne n'était prévenu,
même pas le président libanais Gmael à
l'époque. Donc on a atterri, il était
prévenu une heure avant.
On a atterri, on a été voir les lieux
s'inclinait et cetera et après il
fallait repartir. Mais pour repartir de
l'aéroport Beou, je pense que dans les
gens qui nous écoutent beaucoup de gens
connaissent Beou l'aéroport est au sud,
il faut survoler des quartiers on va
dire potentiellement dangereux dans
lequel il y avait plein de gars qui avut
pouvaient avoir des missiles
des Sam 16
des
des Sam 16 des missiles
par exemple des missiles airs alors
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ? On a fait que
pendant quelques heures où on était à la
résidence des pains, le chef d'étatmajor
particulier, le général Sonier et moi,
on a dit que le président reportait le
lendemain. Finalement, le lendemain, le
surlendemain, c'était pas sûr. On a
brouillé les pistes. Voyez, ça c'est la
première chose. Deuxièmement, il a fait
venir d'un porte-avion qui était pas
loin des super étandards dont la mission
était de se mettre de part et d'autre du
Falcon dans lequel on était
pour intercepter le missile au cas où
pour disperser. Vous savez, vous
connaissez, vous avez le bien connaître
ça,
pour affoler les missiles en fait comme
ils sont guidés par la source de
chaleur. Voilà. Alors donc on arrive, on
est quand même un peu la trouille
franchement. Il y avait dans l'avion, il
y avait qui ? Il y avait le président,
il y avait Sonier
François de Gros, moi je sais plus qui.
On était pas nombreux hein. Et alors
dans l'avion, on commence à rouler
et le président Mitérand une formule
assez étrange, il dit à Sonier le
général, il dit "Général,
dans combien de temps serons-nous si nos
femmes sont veuves ?"
Alors il bafouille un peu, il regarde,
il dit
dans dans 3 minutes, cit le temps du
chirvol, voyez.
Là, il y avait un risque quand même.
Vous parlez d'avion, vous parlez de
survol d'escorte.
Quand on voit le le
ministre russe de la défense se faire
reluquer par la force otanienne en zone
internationale, quand on voit les avions
français se faire reluquer par les
avions russes en zone internationale,
est-ce que ça peut rapidement dégénérer
? Quand vous voyez les bombardiers
russes venir lécher les côtes françaises
juste pour vérifier comme il dit si
l'avion fonctionne bien, est-ce que ça
fait pas partie d'une stratégie de
monter en tension, d'aller se reluquer
dans les airs au lieu de dire
intercepter ou de dire escorté ?
Vous parlez de la Russie là
et je parle de l'OTAN.
Oui, la Russie face à l'OTAN
et de l'OTAN face à la Russie.
On disons, on est dans une phase où
Poutine
qui est un homme très réfléchi, enfin
très bouillonnant à l'intérieur mais
très réfléchi, il observe sans arrêt le
dispositif pour voir où est-ce qu'il y a
des opportunités quand même. Il a pas de
plan d'ensemble, il est pas dingue, il
va pas refaire l'URS. Je sais pas si
vous
est-ce que Est-ce que c'est ce qu'il
veut ?
Oui.
Est-ce qu'il est nostalgique ? Oui,
enfin je sais pas si vous connaissez sa
formule célèbre quand il parle russe.
Ceux qui ceux qui crachent sur l'URSS
n'ont pas de cœur, c'est ça ?
Non, il avait dit pour parler russe
hein, il avait dit celui qui ne regrette
pas l'Union soviétique n'a pas de cœur
mais celui qui veut la reconstituer n'a
pas de tête.
Alors après il a navigué et quand ils
sont une faiblesse une incohérence en
face des éléments troubles, il fait un
coup comme il a fait en Geéorgie, comme
il a fait en Ukraine parce que les
occidentaux mettaient sans arrêt en
avant l'entrée de l'Ukraine dans le
temps en oubliant qu'il y a la Crimée
qui au lieu de tous les Russes, même les
opposants à Poutine,
c'est Russes de point de vue et la base
de Sébastopol.
Donc c'était mis en avant et d'ailleurs
Briginski le conseiller stratégique du
président Carter qui une grande carrière
après qui est l'équivalent de Kissinger.
Voyez comme du côté démocrate Breinski
disait à la fin on a eu tort de les
provoquer avec ça. Il fallait plutôt
organiser la neutralité de l'Ukraine
pour mieux protéger l'Ukraine. Ils
auraient été libres à l'intérieur sur le
plan politique économique et cetera.
Bon, donc il me semble que Poutine
observe et qu'il a une stratégie de
comme il est globalement haï en Europe,
considéré comme la source de tous les
mots et cetera, il joue un peu à ça en
fait. Je crois pas qu'il y a un plan
derrière, je crois pas qu'il y a un plan
d'escalade en tout cas derrière. Et puis
de toute façon, vous me décrivez des
comportements qui ont existé ces
dernières années,
mais il attend les Américains.
C'est d'ailleurs pour ça, sans doute
qu'il n'a pas répondu aux propositions
que je trouvais moi intéressante du
président Macron ou des autres ou des
Allemands. Donc là, il attend Biden,
il va voir Biden le 16 juin
à Genève.
À Genève.
Donc de la part de Poutine, il faut bien
l'évaluer. Les vrais spécialistes, je
parle pas des gens qui condamnent la
Poutine toute la journée, mais les
connaisseurs du système russe disent que
c'est pas un extrémiste dans le système
russe. Évidemment, il a quand même
contribué à réveiller le nationalisme
russe qui était déjà outragé, humilié,
tout enfin réveillé. Et puis
je vous coupe, je vous coupe question
internet.
Excusez-moi,
je vous en prie.
Affaires scripale, Navalnie, fake news
sur les vaccins. Les services russes
sont-ils devenus mauvais ? Action
volontairement mal exécutée ? La Russie
se fait piéger par d'autres services
point d'interrogation.
C'est une bonne question, hein. Moi, je
n'exclus pas que
Poutine n'est plus un contrôle
complet de ses services. En fait, il y a
quand même deux ou trois événements qui
sont produits qui sont complètement
absurdes du point de vue de la stratégie
russe, qui sont très très gênants pour
Poutine et
je crois que il contrôle pas tout, ce
qui est pas une bonne nouvelle, hein.
Pourquoi ? C'estàd qu'on risque de
déclencher une guerre avec des des
déclencher une guerre parce que quand
même les gens contrôlent. Bon enfin, il
peut y avoir des incidents qui
entraînent des engrenages jusqu'à un
certain point jusqu'à ce qu' on mette en
place un mécanisme de déconfliction
comme on dit aujourd'hui.
Question internet.
Que pensent-t-il du traitement
international à l'égard de l'Iran en
général ? Et quels sont les points de
vue sur le rapport de force et
d'influence entre sunnit et chid dans le
monde arabo-musulman ?
C'est deux choses un peu différentes. Ce
qu'on peut dire, c'est que la division
entre les sunnites et les shites qui est
à l'origine de l'islam est plus ou moins
forte selon les moments. Mais c'est pas
ça, il y a pas que ça qui structure le
l'islam. On pourrait même dire que la
bataille énorme qui est en cours à
l'intérieur du monde musulman sunnite
sunnite entre les musulmans en général
les fondamentalistes au sens
traditionnaliste qui sont nombreux mais
minoritaires et les extrémistes y
compris les extrémistes genre
terroristes ça c'est une bataille énorme
à mon avis plus importante que la
bataille entre les chunites et les
chites
après il y a la question chunite chit
Mais elle se ramène beaucoup à la
question Arabie Iran. Voyez ?
Alors sur l'Iran, que dire ? Moi, je
crois que
l'Iran sera un jour un grand pays
émergent
après ce régime ou alors ce régime ayant
été biodégradé par la
monter un peu votre micro.
Donc, je disais client sera un jour à
mon avis un grand pays émergent.
Soit qu'il ce régime soit tombé, soit
qu'il était biodégradé par la société
civile iranienne qui est très puissante,
notamment les femmes. Bon, en tout cas,
il faut compter que l'Iran de demain
alors qu'il y a beaucoup de pays arabes
qui sont quand même minés par des
divisions internes, c'est je c'est pas
évident. Bon, c'est un grand pays
d'avenir quoi l'Iran. Alors aujourd'hui,
on est dans la situation que l'on
connaît. Peut-être que Biden réussira,
je suis pas sûr, à remettre en marche au
moins l'accord qu' avait obtenu Obama
avec deux ou trois ajouts. C'est
possible.
Sur le conflit isra-palestinien, on fait
quoi ?
On C'est qui ?
Nous les Français, est-ce qu'on a un
rôle à jouer ? Est-ce que Est-ce que le
on fait quoi pour que ça s'arrête
?
B conflit israélo-palestinien, il dépend
d'abord des Israéliens. et des
Palestiniens.
Et au-delà des Israéliens, il y a les
les Juifs de la diaspora en France, aux
États-Unis et les organisations autour
de et du côté palestinien, il y a les
pays arabes normalement. Enfin bon, la
réalité des choses, c'est que les Arabes
ont été vaincus à plusieurs reprises.
Ils se sont désintéressés de la question
palestinienne.
La dernière initiative arabe là-dessus,
c'est le plan Abdallah du roi Abdallah
de d'Arabie en 2000
2003, je sais, je me trompe de Lad c'est
assez vieux. C'était un c'était un plan
pas mal d'ailleurs mais qui a gêné la
droite israélienne parce qu'il préfère
avoir des Arabes qui refusent tout que
des Arabes qui font des propositions.
Après, il y a un de pays dont la France
depuis le discours de François Mitan à
la Knesset en mars 82 alors que c'était
un un prou israélien classique avant, il
a compris que il y avait une question
palestinienne très encouragée par le
chancelier autrichien Kryski qui était
un juif moderne apéroche
des proche des disons des travaillistes
en Israël mais pas du tout du reste.
Donc il l'avait encouragé beaucoup.
Émitor fait un discours célèbre en mars
82 envisageant un état pour les
Palestiniens. Après, il y a une longue
longue longue bataille autour de l'idée
de l'État
que les Américains ont ont soutenu plus
ou moins, surtout Bush et Becker qui ont
été courageux, Clinton un peu. Mais en
réalité
en Israël ça évolué dans l'autre sens.
Le pays s'est durcit de plus en plus.
l'arrivée des juifs russes a aggravé ça
d'ailleurs. une des remarques que
Clinton avait fait à Jacques Chirac et
moi la dernière fois qu'on avait été le
voir euh à Washington et on voit bien
que le Lou a gagné, a verrouillé, que et
cetera. Et ces derniers temps, on
pensait que la question palestinienne
avait disparu
parce que Net fort, très doué
politiquement. Il a gagné parce que il y
a eu les accords d'Abraham
paréné par Trump où les pays arabes de
la région qui en fait se fichaent
totalement des Palestiniens avaient
confirmé officiellement ce qui se
passait déjà avant entre les services
secrets par exemple à cause de la peur
de l'Iran en commun. Donc là, il y avait
ces tout derniers mois l'idée que ça y
est, la question a disparu. Elle est pas
réglée, mais elle a disparue. Et ce qui
s'est passé ces dernières semaines en
Israël à partir de la provocation de
colon israélien puis de la provocation
du Hamas sur Israël. Chacun a sa
stratégie et on a vu des Arabes
israéliens plutôt bien intégrés en fait
en Israël se solidariser des
Palestiniens, ce qui est pas le cas
d'habitude. Et
et certains se faire lycher.
Certains se faire lycher. Conclusion, la
question palestienne n'est pas réglée.
On la croyait réglée, elle est pas
réglée. Alors, qu'est-ce qu'on fait
là-dedans ?
Moi, je pense que nous aurions un rôle à
jouer. Nous avons intérêt même tenu de
la sensibilité de la société française
dans toutes ces composantes. Nous
aurions intérêt à
disons à reparler plus fort sur la
question de la l'État palestinien. Mais
il faut en même temps comprendre la la
terreur des Israéliens quoi par rapport
à même si les États-rabes se sont calmés
autour, il y a la siranne, il y a plein
de choses. Donc faut trouver une
formulation qui soit audible.
par une partie des Israéliens, faut pas
les prendre de front, faut pas leur
donner de leçon. Après tous, c'est la la
situation des Palestiniens est
épouvantable, épouvantable notamment à
Gaza.
C'est une prison, c'est une prison
ouvert.
Mais en même temps, il faut comprendre
la psychologie israélienne.
Gaza Gaza, c'est une prison à ciel
ouvert, une concentration.
Oui. Bien sûr. Alors, évidemment, c'est
la politique israélienne mais c'est
aggravé après par le Hamas. Mais si les
pauvres gars Gazains ils ont voté pour
le Hamas, c'est parce que ils avaient
désespéré de toutes les de toutes les
autres options. Mais on peut plus vivre
dans l'idée que cette question ne se
pose plus. Et moi je me demande s'il est
il pourrait pas y avoir un nouveau camp
de la paix en Israël
qui renaîtrait et qui dirait puisqu'on
est entouré d'États arabes pas très pas
amicaux mais enfin pacifiques
qui ne nous pose pas de problème, on a
plus de raison d'avoir peur d'un petit
état palestinien.
Alors je vais peut-être trop vite.
Comment
vous êtes pour une partition ? États.
Non, je suis pas pour faire la partition
mais c'est normalement c'est les textes
internationaux, c'est toute la c'est un
état palestinien aussi Jordanie.
Il aurait fallu faire ça au Rwanda faire
une partition du Rwanda.
J'avoue que j'avais écrit ça il y a très
très longtemps alors que je connaissais
rien au sujet en fait. Et mais je veux
dire pourquoi ? C à cause de la
Tchécoslovaquie.
Donc c'était la c'était après l'Élysée.
dans la période entre l'Élysée et le
Kéoré pour moi et il y avait l'idée
d'une séparation à l'amiable hein
Tchécoslovaque
et j'avais lu je sais pas où donc c'est
après le génocide mais les choses
paraissaient réglé puisque d'ailleurs en
tant que ministre j'ai pu aller parler
de Kagamé et donc j'avais lu quelque
part l'idée que c'était quand même
effrayant ces ces conflits atroces entre
et toutsi depuis des dizaines d'années
depuis le départ des Belges Ronda
Burundi et donc j'avais écrit dans une
un petit un petit papier puis qui vaut
rien en fait qui est pas choquant mais
c'est pas sérieux. L'idée que si dans
l'idéal s'il y avait un pays pour les
Utou, un pays pour les Touti, ça
réglerait peut-être les questions du
Burundi du Rwanda mais je reconnais que
je l'avais fait sans
parce que les couples mixes était
compliqué. Non,
faut dire que en France, il y a
quasiment aucun spécialiste de de
l'Afrique centrale.
Évidemment aucun dans la commission du
CL mais ni ailleurs dans les gens qui
parlent du sujet. S'il y a un
spécialiste qui est Gérard Prunier, lui
c'est un peut-être un des vrais
spécialistes qui connaît le sujet mais
ma proposition était complètement
question internet surtout
encore était pas mal inspiré ni
choquante mais complètement
impraticable. Question internet son
point de vue sur BHL comme géopolitique
philosophe influenceur
et de la dangerosité du personnage.
Écoutez, les influenceurs sont dangereux
quand il y a des décideurs qui se
laissent influencer hein. Sinon, ils
sont pas dangereux. Mais je consacre
dans le livre dont vous parlez. Je
regrette trop peu puis c'est peut-être
l'occasion.
Je t'en d perche. Je t'en d perche.
Il est dedans. Il était temps
être mauvaise langue.
Bon donc je constat une entrée à VHL
mais je suis assez euh je suis assez
balancé. Je suis pas je suis pas
méchant, je suis pas d'accord avec lui
puisque je conclus que sa vision du
monde c'est la vision dans laquelle
l'Occident après avoir évangélisé le
monde entier il doit radomiser le monde
entier. Et donc faut que il écrit c'est
il avait écrit ce livre sous Trump en
disant puisque Trump abandonne la
mission civilisatrice ou la mission
universelle de l'Occident, il faut que
les Européens la reprennent la
reprennent. Et donc ça nous amène à
entrer en conflit façon très nette avec
la Russie, la Chine, la Turquie, l'Iran,
l'Arabie et je ne sais quoi encore. Donc
c'est pas ton LOcident va pas se lancer
là-dedans. C'est pas possible. Faut
rentrer être très malin en étant très
très réal politicien et en divisant les
pays qui nous sont hostiles, voyez. Mais
j'en parle pas méchamb en fait parce que
c'est quelqu'un, il se trouve que je
suis souvent pas d'accord avec ses idées
ou ce qu'il écrit mais je le connais
personnellement et il est extrêmement
gentil en fait. Il est gentil,
sympathique, il est fidèle en amitié
donc c'est quelqu'un qui est plus c'est
plus complexe que ce que l'on croit.
Donc je ne réagis pas qu'à ses propos,
voyez.
François de gros rouvre,
gros souvre. Grosso ouvre, pardon. Euh
vous pouvez parler un petit peu sur ce
sujet-là ? Oh
oui, c'est un c'est un industriel
Lyonnais qui avait fait la connaissance
de François Miton sous la 4e République.
Résistant
résist ou Oui, résistant résistant et
après oui, résist
croix de guerre. de guerre,
résistant pendant la guerre et puis
après il était entré dans les systèmes
secrets de l'OTAN, vous savez après et
donc il avait fait la connaissance
de Mitteran sur la 4e. Il était pris de
passion pour Mitteran un coup de foudre
complètement séduit par Mitan. à tel
point qu'il a en partie financé et
organisé le voyage que Françoitan avait
fait en Chine en en 1900
je sais plus combien 60 61 sous la 4e
non c'est il faut pas que je me trompe
je crois que c'est après le retour au
pouvoir du général de Gaulle et François
avait rencontré Maung je sais pas
comment d'ailleurs il avait réussi et il
avait pris position pour la
reconnaissance de la Chine de Mao par la
France
un peu avant que le général de Gaulle le
décide après avoir envoyé de Garfort.
Donc Grossau a été très important et par
la suite il a toujours été auprès de
François Mitérand il a contribué à
l'aider financièrement parce que Mit
n'est pas de fortune particulière à
l'époque il y a pas de réglementation,
il y a pas de financement public de la
vie politique. C'est longtemps après,
c'est sous Mitéran et Rocard qu'on a mis
en place des des lois de ce type. Donc
c'était un homme, un compagnon
que que j'aimais bien, qui était un côté
un peu vieille France,
distingué, un peu à côté de la plaque en
fait. Et il avait vraiment rêvé dans
cette longue période d'être nommé pas
François Mitteran à un grand poste si
Mitteran était élu. Mais Mitteran avait
conscience de l'attachement de Français
de Grosou mais de ses limites aussi ou
de enfin il était pas fait pour les
postes qui l'ambitionnaient. Il vou être
patron de la patron de la DGSE, patron
d'Air France, des choses comme ça. Alors
après, c'est triste parce qu'il en a
conçu un une grande amertume.
Voilà, au fil du temps et puis il a fini
par se suicider dans l'Élysée quand
même, pas un mélange de de dépit
politique, de dépit amoureux, de dépit
de vie privée, enfin tout un toute un
espèce de mélange. Mais Français
Mitéran, ne rompez pas avec les gens. Il
y a d'ailleurs un documentaire il y a
quelques temps par Gérard Miller, bien
fait
sur les vrais vieux amis de Miteran et
le titre c'est l'homme qui n'aimait pas
rompre.
Alors Groschou était resté dans le
circuit mais il s'occupait que des
chasses voyez des choses comme ça. Il
était triste.
OK.
Alors il voulait quand même s'occuper de
choses importantes parce que quand je
suis devenu moi euh le jeune conseiller
diplomatique que personne n'attendait.
il voulait absolument s'occuper du
Liban. Donc il m'appelait tout le temps
pour parler de ses idées sur Liban, ce
qu'il fallait faire et que les Gmail et
cetera. Mais c'était un homme la fin est
triste mais c'était un homme attachant.
Question internet. Pensez-vous qu'un
choc des civilisations est un sens
aujourd'hui ?
Malheureusement, je peux pas répondre
non.
Alors dans le débat entre Fukuyama,
c'est la fin de l'histoire parce que la
démocratie a gagné démocratie de marché
nana. Et Huntington qui répond en disant
"Mon pauvre ami, vous êtes trop naïf.
Nous sommes au contraire menacés d'un
choc des civilisations." Vous savez, il
y a cette classification
en h grandes civilisations qui étaient
très contesté mais quand Brodel faisait
ça, personne ne hlait. Bon, c'est un
truc classique. Les relig les la batrise
des civilisations étant les religions
par rapport à ça. Et moi, je pense qu'il
y a un risque quand même. Donc le risque
n'est pas écarté. Alors évidemment, il y
a
il y a des civilisations plus ou moins
antagonistes par rapport aux autres. Il
y a plein de conflits à l'intérieur des
civilisations. Vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure de la
de la question sunichit par exemple mais
quand même et alors Huntington il voyait
une alliance du monde musulman et du
monde chinois qui appelle Confuéen
contre l'Occident.
Alors, on n'est pas du tout dans ce cas
de figure, notamment à cause du Syong,
mais en ce qui concerne les relations du
monde musulman
avec les problèmes qu'il a aujourd'hui
et les autres,
moi je crois que le risque n'est pas
complètement écarté
parce qu'il y a à l'intérieur du monde
musulman et à l'intérieur du monde
occidental des gens qui jouent le clash.
Mais pour être honnête avec Samington,
il faut rappeler qu'il n'a jamais
préconisé le clash.
Et quand les gens de l'administration
américaine George W Bush s'inspirit de
lui, c'était à tort. D'ailleurs, un
jour, j'arrive à l'Élysée pour
l'entretien avec le président Chirac. Il
me dit "Moi, je condamne cette théorie
du choc des civilisations."
Et j'ai dit "Mais moi, je pense qu'il
vaut mieux combattre le risque."
Le boycotte,
lequel ?
Bah, il y a une entrée dans votre livre
qui sur le boycotte. Ça veut dire quoi
le boycotte ? au 21e siècle.
Et ben le boycott, c'est quand on décide
de boycotter un produit, une
personnalité, une organisation et
cetera.
Une élection,
ça marche quand on est fort quoi. C'est
comme les sanctions. Non, c'est ça peut
marcher mieux que les sanctions. Alors
après, il y a des boycottes qui sont
compréhensibles, voire légitime ou
l'égau et d'autres qui sont choquants.
Voyez ? Mais vous savez, dans le monde
actuel, on est très interdépendant.
C'est pas encore la communauté, c'est
une foire d' poigne. Donc toutes les
puissances grandes, moyennes, petites
essaient d'influencer les autres. Alors
soit par la force, la force armée, la
dissuasion,
le dollar pour les États-Unis et cetera,
mais tous les autres ont des moyens. Il
y a des diasporas, il y a des lobbyes,
il y a des trucs. Bon voilà et le
boycott en fait partie.
Quand est-ce que ça marche ? Quand
est-ce que ça marche pas ?
Question internet. Est-ce qu'un jour H
Uber Vidrine va faire la géopolitique
pour les nuls ?
Alors, je sais pas est-ce que c'est déjà
fait ou pas
par Hubert Vedrine ? Peut-être pas.
Non, mais est-ce que le livre ressemble
à ça ?
Non, pas du tout.
Non, mais la série géopolitique pour les
nuls, elle est très bien. Enfin, la
série pour les nuls, elle est très bien.
C'est une sorte de disons de de remise à
niveau culture générale où il y a tous
les éléments basiques. C'est pas le cas
de mon livre là.
C'est pas le cas parce qu'au contraire,
je comment dire, je je
dis des choses un peu décalées, un peu
malicieuses, un peu ironiques sur
beaucoup de sujet où pour des raisons de
d'expérience et de réflexion, je suis
arrivé à pas tout à fait penser comme
l'opinion dominante, mais je fais pas
par respect de contradiction ni par
idéologique. C'est pas du tout
idéologique.
Je peux être dans des postures
inversées. Regardez qui a toujours été
très très méfiant par rapport à l'idée
de l'ingérance, du droit d'ingérence. Je
suis par les hasards de l'histoire
obligé d'expliquer la fière du Rwanda.
Alors que c'est le contraire de moi j'ai
toujours été plutôt contre l'ingérence.
Donc il y a beaucoup d'autres cas où je
suis un peu à contre-pied mais c'est
plutôt pour faire réfléchir pour
intriguer. Donc c'est pas la
géopolitique pour les nuls qui est un
truc méthodique calme et qui qui reprend
tous les fondamentaux. Donc la réponse
c'est que non je ferai pas ça. Donc si
le monsieur qui a posé la question veut
bien le faire, il le fait.
Question question internet. La France
est-elle encore une grande puissance sur
la scène internationale ? Dans quel
domaine ? Point d'interrogation. Et moi,
j'ajoute, est-ce que la France n'est pas
devenue une puissance de moyenne
impuissance ?
Bon, c'est un vieux débat.
Je pense que la France se demande si
elle est encore une grande puissance
depuis 1815 au Congrès de Vienne où par
le génie de Taleran, on est réintégré
dans le cancer européen qui va gérer le
l'Europe pendant un siècle.
Même question en 1870
Napoléon 3 s'est fait piéger par Bismarc
qui était quand même plus fort. Alors en
1918, on a cru l'inverse
d'autant qu'on avait la première armée
du monde puisque'à l'époque on
raisonnait en terme quantitatif pour
l'armée de terre. C'était la plus grande
armée défilé des maréchauds après le
tous les tous les grands maréchaud de
l'époque
après la guerre de la victoire 1918. et
on est un peu intoxiqué par ça dans les
années 20 et 30 à tel point qu'on ne
mesure pas les les risques qui arrivent
et le général de Gaulle est terriblement
seul. Après, il y a le vrai coup de
massu
qui est l'effondrement de juin 40
de juin 40. Le moment donc le plus bas
de l'histoire c'est la désagrégation
et tout ce qui se passe de tellement
déplorable après les collaborations et
cetera, c'est un chou-produit. C'est un
sous-produit de la désagrégation de la
France 40. Donc le vrai problème c'est
ça. Alors après de Gaulle génialement
et les autres présidents y compris
Mitérand qui est important parce qu'on
croyait que la gauche dire le contraire
de de Gaul et des successeurs. Ils ont
repris l'idée de la France et De Gaul
était très loin parce qu'il prétendaiit
que la France était libérée par
elle-même.
Mais c'est pas c'est pas vrai, c'est le
débarquement. Bon et cetera. Mais ça ça
avait une fonction à un moment donné,
une fonction thérapeutique.
Alors à l'arrivée, les Français voient
bien les résultats, les trucs. Alors
quand j'étais questionné comme ministre,
parce que c'est permanent cette
question, je disais est une puissance
moyenne d'influence mondiale et c'est
important d'être une puissance parce
qu'il y en a qu'une quinzaine sur les
200 des Nations Unies. C'est déjà
extraordinaire, hein. Puissance moyenne
encore là d'influence mondiale, c'est
vrai parce que dans certains domaines,
on a décroché même par rapport à
l'Allemagne, on l'a bien vu récemment
sur le numérique, on a raté le coche,
même si c'est un français qui avait
inventé la carte à puce. Bon, il y a
plein de choses comme ça. Et donc, on a
quand même la dissuasion, on a le
conseil de sécurité. J'en ai parlé à
propos de le la malheureuse affaire du
Rwanda. On a quand même la francophonie.
Alors, c'est pas nous qui la manipulons,
personne la manipule mais c'est
malheureuse et dramatique situation
et on a on a il y a une image dans la
tête des gens sur la France, c'est pas
toujours la même. Moi j'ai Schwenl se
référer à la commune par exemple.
D'autres noms ? Le président Jemin, le
chinois qui m'avait reçu quand j'étais
en visite là-bas comme ministre, il
m'avait lu en français
quelques lignes de Victor Hugo qui avait
pris le qui avait condamné le sac du
palais d'été par les troupes françaises
qui avait envoyé là-bas après la vous
savez l'affaire des boxeurs et cetera.
Bon donc les autres n'ont pas tous la
même France en tête mais je pense qu'il
y a encore quelque chose de
considérable.
C'est pas que Louis XIV, c'est pas que
Napoléon qui est à double tronchant, ce
n'est pas que de Gaulle. Il y a des
éléments très très forts quand même,
mais ce n'est pas utilisable par des
dirigeants. C'est puis a la gastronomie,
à Paris, enfin à Paris quand on quand on
peut circuler, bon et cetera et cetera.
Donc donc il y a il y a beaucoup
d'atoumission un peu diffus et c'est
vrai que si vous prenez le tableau
froid, les puissances actuelles,
les puissances moyennes et vous mettez
les les émergents et ben tous les
statisticiens et les économistes nous
disent
et ben à tel moment l'Inde passe devant
tel pays et puis la la Grande-Bretagne
est dépassée puis la France est dépassée
puis l'Allemagne est dépassée.
qu'on voit bien qu'en 20 ou 30 ans,
c'est pas que le français la remarque,
c'est global, en 20 ou 30 ans, il y a
une redistribution de la puissance
dans le monde où on est encore là. Alors
après, on retombe sur le dilemme
permanent. Est-ce qu'on est là en tant
que tel ou est-ce qu'il faut pas jouer
la carte de l'Europe ? Est-ce que
l'Europe est encore un levier ou est-ce
que c'est pas au contraire quelque chose
dans lequel on va perdre le peu qu'on a
gardé ? pas tout le monde connaît ça
mais voilà
donc mais je reprends pas moyenne
impuissance parce que ça va trop loin.
Il y a des domaines c'est pas vrai, il y
a des domaines où c'est pire.
On arrive bientôt à la fin de notre
interview. Certains vous accusent d'être
un relais de Poutine, un influenceur de
la Russie. Qu'est-ce que vous leur
répondez ?
Je sais pas qui peut dire ça. C'est
totalement
Je sais même pas sur quoi ça repose en
fait.
Moi, j'ai j'ai joué un rôle important
auprès de François Mitéran
quand on a mené une politique
d'équilibre des forces en Europe.
Il y avait la menace des SS20 ici la
moyenne portée qui menaçait l'Europe de
l'Ouest et il y avait la question est-ce
qu'il fallait mettre des perchings ou
pas ? Toutes les gauches européennes
disaient faut pas provoquer les Russes.
Il faut expliquer ce que c'est un
perching à notre
c'est des missiles à tête nucléaire à
moyenne portée.
Bon donc les Russes en avaient mis pour
des raisons débiles parce qu'ils avaient
déjà les arbres stratégiques mais
c'était le le complexe militaire
industriel russe et tout ça. Donc il y
avait un débat Mitérand était très
courageux en disant soit les Russes
retirent leur missiles
soit on accepte les perching. Il a fait
un discours au bout de slag magnifique
en janvier 83 et il a dit quelques mois
plus tard euh dans un voyage à
Bruxelles, il a une formule magnifique
inventé Mitéran, il avait pas de
speechriter hein, c'était en général
lui. Mais dans quelques grands grands
discours, c'était quand même la trame
était préparée. Et donc mon mon adjoint
de l'époque Jean-Michel Gaillard avait
eu cette idée géniale.
Les michiles sont à l'est et les
pacifistes sont à l'ouest.
Donc moi, je suis de l'école équilibre
des forces, école réal politique. Je me
moque dans le livre de l'irréal
politique dans laquelle nous baignions.
Bon
quoi
? C'est la croyance des Européens. Le
monde est une communauté. On varie les
rapports de force sont dépassés, on va
on va on va rayonner par nos valeurs et
blab blabla et cetera. Ça serait très
sympa s'il y avait 9 milliards
d'Européens de l'Ouest. Voyez non mais
c'est pas du tout le cas. Bon donc après
moi j'ai participé avec au côté de
Mitteran à tous les efforts faits pour
accompagner Gorbatchov
et l'aider à imaginer un avenir au-delà
du communisme en Urs. Ça a pas marché,
ça a capoté. Gorbatchev était trop
utopiste, ça a pas fonctionné. Mit avait
une idée géniale mais qu'il a torpillé
lui-même en la lançant trop tôt qui
était l'idée de la Confédération
européenne Europe, Russie et cetera.
Bon, par la suite, moi je me suis borné
à dire quand j'étais ministre, j'ai
rencontré Poutine. Il est là depuis
tellement longtemps que je l'ai
rencontré moi au début quand tu quand
j'étais ministre, il venait de devenir
président. Tout à fait au début. Je je
suis borné à dire des choses qui sont
pas du tout des positions prorusses.
C'est pas prorusse. Qu'est-ce que je dis
en général ? Que je ne comprends pas,
qu'on ait plus peur de Poutine que de
l'URS.
Quand l'URS était ultra puissante,
nucléaire conventionnel, armes
chimiques, assassinat d'ancien
transfuge, tous et machins, beaucoup
plus que la Russie et bien il commume
des présidents américains soutenus par
des présidents français ou de par de
Gaul ou d'autres pour dire on va
négocier avec l'URS et on a négocié. On
n'a pas eu peur, on n' pas eu la
trouille, on n' pas eu peur de
nous-même. Et tous les grands accords de
désarmement ou de contrôle désarmement,
c'est grâce à ça, c'est grâce au
réalisme. Donc je dis aujourd'hui, c'est
quand même ridicule d'avoir en Europe
une espèce de trouille comme si on avait
perdu la guerre froide. C'est pas le
cas. C'est pas le cas. Et donc, je pense
qu'il faut être capable de parler avec
Poutine, de négocier avec lui tout en
étant très ferme d'Uasion nucléaire
conventionnelle. Il y a des
cyberattaques, faut répliquer par des
cyberattaques. Je suis pas du tout mçon
moi là-dessus. Si on peut oui, mais il
faut être capable. Je comprends que à
votre mimique que vous pensez qu'on n
pas Et ben moi j'ai dit soyons capable,
faisons-le. Et s'il y a trop d'avions
qui vont essayer de frôler les
dispositifs de l'OTAN, répliquons. Donc
je suis pas du tout du tout pour une
position de faiblesse. D'abord parce que
je pense que ça aide Poutine si on est
ferme à contenir ses extrémistes à lui
ou ses services à lui. Mais il faut
aller au-delà, faut voir au-delà. Il y a
une Russie, c'est un grand pays, c'est
une vraie culture. Il y a il y a des
gens qui faut parler. On voit pas assez
les Russes, on y va pas. Je parle je
parle pas des dirigeants, hein. On voit
pas assez les bah les internautes, les
gens comme vous qui créent des qui qui
créent des systèmes comme ça en Russie.
On voit passer les créateurs, les
peintres, les architectes, les médecins.
Il faudrait qu'il y ait beaucoup plus
d'échanges entre les sociétés civiles
d'Europe occidentale, d'Europe de l'Est
et de la Russie. C'est beaucoup plus
important. Enfin, ça complète les
postures militaires. Donc c'est pas être
prusse ni pro Poutine. Donc je crois que
nous faisons fausse route. Je pense
qu'on a mal utiliser les deux premiers
mandats de PuTine où il était assez euh
assez ouvert, assez demandeur en fait,
assez demandeur par rapport à
l'Occident. Je pense que l'engrenage
Ukraine était évitable par une politique
plus intelligente. Je reconnais qu'on
est un peu coincé maintenant en fait
parce qu'il y a il a réveillé le
nationalisme russe et l'alliance avec
l'église orthodoxe et puis en fait il
attendait les États-Unis.
Il avait cru qu'avec Trump ça allait
s'améliorer. Ça pas été le cas. Trump
n'a pas pu. Biden est très très dur sur
Poutine mais il va le voir. Il va pas
simplement le voir pour l'insulter.
et tous les Européens qui se sont
concentrés ces dernières années dans la
dénonciation de Poutine sans arrêt sur
tous les sujets, ce qui est souvent
fondé d'ailleurs, ils ont pas vu au-delà
à un moment donné, on dit il faut quand
même parler avec eux. On a des questions
de sécurité en Europe. Il faut
renégocier des accords de maîtrise des
armements. Il y a des domaines de
coopération future dans l'avenir de
l'écologie dont on a pas parlé mais il
faudrait 3h de plus. La menace
climatique est-elle une priorité par
risque de déstabilisation géopolitique ?
Et la question est double. Quel est son
point de vue sur ce qu'il se passe
autour des voies maritimes du nord ?
Autour des
voies maritimes du nord ?
Bah c'est très grave la question de
l'article. Oui, c'est très grave ça.
Alors moi, je dirais pas que la menace
climatique est une menace pour la
géopolitique.
Les menaces écologiques en général sont
une menace pour la vie sur terre.
C'est même pas une menace sur la
planète.
C'est pas la planète qui intéresse,
c'est les habitants de la planète. Moi,
je pense ça depuis des années, hein.
J'aiécris un livre il y a longtemps qui
s'appelait le monde au défi qui était
là-dessus. Mais c'est pas que le climat
parce que l'effondrement de la
biodiversité, la surpêche, il y a plein
de choses qui sont effrayantes aussi. Et
je crois que c'est un c'est à prendre
très très au sérieux mais je suis faut
que je sois honnête, je suis du pas du
tout du côté des écologistes politique.
Je pense qu'il délire complètement et
que ils ont fait une erreur monstrueuse
depuis plusieurs décennies en se
concentrant que sur le nucléaire dont on
peut pas se passer pendant encore une
génération et qui d'ailleurs n'im pas de
CO2 et se concentrer sur le charbon
contre le charbon. C'est quand madame
Merkel pour des raisons d'alliance
électorale est sorti du nucléaire trop
tôt, il faudra sortir un jour mais trop
tôt, qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait ? Elle a
relancé le charbon en Allemagne. Bon
donc les écologistes politiques qui font
des choses, qui sont demandées par des
électorats bobo de centre-ville, bon
c'est complètement hors sujet. Nous, la
France grâce au NCL, on fait 1 % du CO2
mondial.
On représente combien ?
Non, mais je veux dire que c'est pas la
priorité pour nous. La priorité pour
nous, c'est pas d'empoisonner les gens
des centre-villes. La priorité c'est la
transformer l'agroindustrie.
Parce que l'agroindustrie, on est
là-dessus, on est très performant. Donc
on apporterait plus en exemple au monde
en se concentrant là-dessus. Voyez donc
il y a un vrai euh il y a un vrai sujet
et moi j'empl le terme d'écologisation
comme on disait industrialisation parce
que c'est un c'est une dynamique c'est
un processus alors qu'écologie c'est
statique donc on va tout devoir
écologiser on va écologiser l'industrie,
l'agriculture, les transports, la
construction et cetera. C'est déjà
commencé.
Il y a des millions de gens qui
travaillent là-dessus, mais c'est pas
des gens qui défilent dans la rue avec
des slogans inutiles. C'est des
chercheurs, ce sont des ingénieurs, ce
sont des entrepreneurs, des gens qui
investissent, des gens qui commencent à
transformer les mastodontes de
l'industrie d'avant prédatrice ou et
cetera en autre chose. Ça ça va dominer
les prochaines décennies.
Alors ça menace pas la géopolitique, ça
va la modifier
parce qu'il va apparaître à un moment
donné qu'il y a une compétitivité
écologique et les pays qui ont réussi à
bien se situer sont en meilleure posture
que les autres. C'est pour ça dire que
les réunions consacrées à l'écologie,
les copes les copes sur le climat, sur
la biodiversité, il y a il y a une cope
biodiversité à l'automne en Chine. Je
pense ça va devenir plus important que
le G7 par exemple comme rendez-vous. Et
alors là, les États doivent les États et
les entreprises surtout doivent être à
mon avis à la pointe, mais pas plus
parce qu'une entreprise qui va aller
troup en avant
va être éliminée, elle sera plus du tout
en table en fait. Donc faut être un peu
en avant, faut être stimulant, faut pas
être en arrière. Et j'ajouterai un mot
économique
devant beaucoup de gens dans le monde de
l'entreprise, l'industrie, l'économie,
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on se sert du PIB
qui est un instrument très frustre en
fait qui mesure les flux simplement, pas
les patrimoines, pas les stocks. Bon
aujourd'hui, par hypothèse, on rage une
forêt entière,
la forêt de Fontainebleu, par exemple
et puis on construit que des usines
polluantes à la place. Bon, on peut pas
pour 36000 raisons, mais ce serait de la
croissance.
Donc c'est la fameuse destruction
créatrice, c'est ça
comment ? la fameuse destruction
créatrice.
Alors, il faut appliquer les pensées de
Schumpeter justement à la à la création
écologique. Mais le jour où on aura fait
entrer dans le calcul économique
à partir du prix du carbone et de plein
d'autres choses, la valeur patrimoniale,
le fait qu'une forêt absorbe du CO2, que
les océans font ceci, cela, le jour on
arrivera à les chiffrer. C'est les gars
qui font ça, ils méritent le prix Nobel
et d'écologie et d'économie, hein. Bon,
peut-être de la paix.
et peut-être de la paix. Oui, bien sûr.
À ce moment-là, ça entre dans le calcul
économique et on n pas besoin de disons
de d'avocat zellés de l'écologie. On n
pas besoin d'illuminés de l'écologie. On
a besoin d'un mode de calcul qui montre
à n'importe quel investisseur un peu
cocaïné, un peu fou, voyez, que il vaut
mieux prendre une décision plutôt qu'une
autre. Non pas parce qu'il est un
amoureux de l'écologie, mais parce que
les chiffres de la rentabilité nous
montrent que son choix d'avant est
devenu périmé.
C'est ça qu'il faut viser et je pense
qu'on va y arriver. Ça bouge énormément
en fait. Ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'écologie plaintive, punitive,
expiatrice. Rien. Je suis content que
vous ayez posé quand même cette cette
question parce que ça rééclaire un peu
tout.
Tout est intim,
tout est intimement connecté, hein.
Est-ce que vous voyez un sujet qu'on a
pas abordé, que vous voulez aborder avec
nous ?
Ben oui, il y a 240 entrées du livre.
Ouais. Non, on avait dit qu'on avait que
3 heures.
Juste une, ça nous ça nous suffira.
Ben, qu'est-ce que je peux dire pour
prendre des sujets sensibles
contemporain ? Euh que par exemple dans
le grand débat entre histoire et
mémoire, je suis du côté de l'histoire,
moi. Je suis du côté de Pierre Nora, je
me méfie du devoir de mémoire parce que
non pas que je le je veux pas avoir
l'air d'un monstre, je pas je condamne
pas les arrièrespensées éthiques,
morales et cetera. Mais le devoir de
mémoire, c'est toujours une construction
qui nous en dit beaucoup sur le pays, le
lieu et le moment où c'est fabriqué.
On parlait de l'esclavage dans
et alors que l'histoire de l'alcool de
Raymon René Raymond
et Pierre Nora sur l'histoire. Je crois
l'histoire, la vérité historique.
C'est les vainqueurs qui écrivent
l'histoire. Non,
c'est
les vainqueurs
pendant un certain temps. Oui, oui,
c'est vrai, bien sûr. Mais ça s'arrête
jamais. Voyez, on peut toujours débattre
des raisons pour lesquelles Jules César
a déclenché la guerre des Gaules par
exemple. Donc ça s'arrête jamais. On
peut revenir là-dessus. Mais c'est un
terrain que je trouve plus solide. Je
crois pas que ce soit des je crois pas
que ce soit le rôle des assemblées de
faire des lois mémorielles pour dire la
vérité historique. C'est ça. Après, on
change de majorité, ils vont voter autre
chose. C'est absurde. Donc je crois
beaucoup plus à la à l'histoire. Il faut
que ce soit très ouvert. Il faut qu'il
ait toutes les contributions et je parle
pas d'une histoire qui serait enfermée
dans l'histoire de France ou dans
l'histoire de la Grande-Bretagne ou de
l'Allemagne. Il faut qu'il y ait des des
circulations. Bien sûr.
Est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Alors dans quel domaine ?
À vous de choisir des livres qui vous
trois livres. Trois livres à lire.
Trois livres importants pour Uber
Vidrine
B
pour rester dans le domaine de la
géopolitique, on a tourné un peu autour
dans cet entretien
ou de votre vie.
Ouais,
il y a tellement de livres.
Bah j'ai je vais en citer en tout cas un
un livre récent aux belles lettres sur
le plan Marchal.
C'est passionnant parce qu'on voit que
autour de Grosevel Pitrouan, les
Américains réfléchissent avant même la
victoire finale sur Hitler et sur les
Japonais. à la suite, ils réfléchissent
à l'Europe de demain et tous les débats
qui ont lieu des années après entre les
Belges, les Français, les Allemands, ils
ont lu avant entre Américains.
Et alors l'idée des Américains déjà,
c'est qu'il faut relancer l'économie de
l'Europe de l'Ouest
avant même qu' la menace talinienne et
que donc faut imaginer la gestion. Après
leur grand problème à l'époque, c'est
qu'ils craignent que les Français, on
est en 44, voyez, que les Français soi
absolument opposés à toute coopération
avec l'Allemagne. Ils ont peur que les
Français raisonnent comme Clémanceau.
Ils veulent que l'Allemagne soit
raptissée, découpé en morceaux et
cetera. Donc il y a plein de plein
d'idées américaines
et c'est là où ils arrivent à ce qui
sera plus tard le plan marchal mais il y
a déjà l'idée avant d'un grand plan
économique avec l'idée que ça les
dispensera de faire une alliance
atlantique parce qu'ils veulent pas une
alliance militaire c'est les embêter et
le Sénat contre surtout pas d'article 5
qui est oblige à se porter au secours
des autres et donc quand on lit ça le
plan Marchal donc que je recommande
vraiment et puis il y a tous les débats,
il y a toutes les archives, c'est
absolument passionnant, on voit que ça
conduit
Le plan marchal conduit quand même à
l'Alliance atlantique parce qu'à un
moment donné les Européens le demandent
tellement que les États-Unis ne peuvent
plus le refuser et ça conduit à la
construction européenne.
Et en fait les vrais pères fondateurs de
la construction européenne c'est pas
Jean Monet Schuman et compagnie c'est
Staline par la menace et Truman par la
réponse. C'est un livre très éclairant.
Alors d'autre part je vais citer un
livre puisque lequel je m'en est donné.
l'un de mes vieux amis qui était à l'én
avec moi, Philippe Saint-Marcot qui
était à un moment donné le dauphin de de
fer et puis ça tourné autrement. Mais
son père était un formidable gouverneur
de la France d'outre mer, gouverneur
Jeanmarco notamment au Cameroun très
proche de Deffer. Il a eu fait avec lui
pendant la 4e République la fameuse loi
cadre qui a préparé l'évolution de des
colonies françaises d'Afrique vers
l'indépendance. Il a fait un livre passé
complètement inaperçu
il y a 2 ans chez un éditeur qui
s'appelle le petit éditeur et il reprend
toute l'histoire de la colonisation et
toute l'histoire de la décolonisation et
tout tout le débat postcolonial.
C'est passionnant et c'est assis sur une
érudition dingue. Il a tout lu tout lu
pour chaque chapitre. Il y a 30 livres.
Il a fait ça toute sa vie. Et ça nous
amène à un regard qui est complètement
différent, qui est ni pour ni jamais
binaire, voyez, c'est jamais
schématique. Mais la façon dont ça s'est
passé, l'histoire de l'Afrique, il adore
l'Afrique. Il est né d'ailleurs au
Cameroun, dans la région de la forêt
équatoriale. Et donc ce regard sur le
alors pour alors du coup, j'ai pas le je
pas sûr du titre euh je crois que c'est
pour sortir de l'impasse
sortir de l'impasse postconial, je
crois.
C'est formidable, c'est passionnant,
c'est émouvant, c'est intéressant et ça
éclaire tous nos débats actuels
sur esclavage, colonisation, histoire et
cetera, mais d'une façon qui est jamais
binaire,
qui est toujours
humaniste, c'est subtilement complexe.
Un petit dernier. Non,
il il y en a tellement. Qu'est-ce qui me
faudra mais que je change de domaine ?
Non, vous savez, je dis tellement de par
ailleurs de de polar de choses comme ça.
Vous avez le droit à Polar si vous
voulez.
Vous avez le droit au polarin.
Bah écoutez, j'ai trouvé magnifiquement
écrit le livre de Pauline Drefus
sur Paul Moran. C'est une biographie.
Paul Moran est un personnage peu
ragoutant si ce n'est dégoûtant à
certains moments mais la trajectoire est
très intéressante.
C'est très bien écrit, c'est un vrai
écrivain. Un vrai écrivain qui il faut
retenir son nom, Pauline Drefus. Et donc
c'est toute l'histoire année 30, année
40 et la suite,
c'est sortir de l'impasse postcolonial.
C'est ça.
Voilà. Bravo.
Il faut dire merci à la communauté qui
nous suiv en direct. Ben, je remercie la
personne qui a dit ça et
Manuel,
ben c'est bien. Bravo.
Et pendant votre 19 ans au pouvoir,
avant de donner un un conseil pour les
jeunes générations, est-ce que pendant
ces 19 ans, vous avez fait des erreurs ?
Est-ce que vous avez un regret ?
Bah, les erreurs, il y en a plein parce
que quand vous donnez des conseils tout
le temps, d'abord c'est terrifiant quand
vous devenez conseiller d'un président.
C'est pas le café du commerce. On peut
dire tout et le contraire de tout, on
s'en fiche. Bon ou dans un chat, on peut
dire des choses brusquement. Au début,
j'ai le prix d'un vertige
ah oui, je conseille ça. Mais si par
hasard il suit mon idée, qu'est-ce qui
va se passer ? Voyez, ça c'est le début
ça. Alors après avec le recul bien sûr,
il y a des ça four, j'ai pas de souvenir
d'erreur majeure.
Un regret. Alors
alors des regrets, il y en a plein mais
vraiment j'ai par exemple j'ai cru avec
toute l'équipe de L a commencé par le
président d'ailleurs j'ai cru qu'on
aurait vraiment une influence au proche
Orient
et moi j'ai passé un nom incalculable de
temps à voir des Israéliens partisans de
la paix, des Palestiniens partisans de
la paix dont certains se sont fait
assassiner à cause de ça et cetera. Donc
des occasions très très nombreuses. On y
était. le président y croyait quand même
ça. Donc j'ai participé de de cet élan
et puis je me dis après en fait on a
toujours eu presque aucun levier et les
Américains en ont enfin ils osent pas
l'employer. Donc ça c'est des regrets.
Il y en a un que j'ai cité concernant
Mitéran qui est évident c'est la l'idée
de la confédération qui était une idée
géniale. Il fait pas la lancer le 31
décembre 89, il est lancé de Latu
conseiller tout ça. changer complètement
la négociation sur l'adhésion des pays
d'Europe de l'Est et donc la psychologie
et les relations aujourd'hui. Et
peut-être puis on a on n pas réussi à à
faire admettre aux autres occidentaux
qu'il fallait traiter la Russie non pas
comme un vaincu négligeable mais comme
un partenaire qu'il fallaitonsabiliser
dans l'affaire du Ronda dont on en a
tant parlé. Moi, j'ai un regret
gigantesque, c'est que Mit n'a jamais
expliqué sa politique. Donc ce que
j'essaie laborieusement de d'expliquer,
non pas que j'ai joué le moindre rôle,
mais je me sens tenu par la loyauté puis
c'est la France, c'est pas que Miteran,
c'est maladure, Jup, l'amiralade,
l'armée, tout ça. Donc, j'essaie
d'expliquer les décisions, la les dates,
les chronologies. Vous avez l'impression
d'être un émissaire politique de la
politi
et même chose et ça serait complètement
différent. Voyez dans l'affaire à la
bande je trouve qu'il ils ont été
géniaux tous collectivement ils ont très
bien géré la la fin de l'URS et donc la
rification monde qui est un
sous-produit. George Bouche Père
Gorbatchef malgré son angoisse de la
finor Col Mitéron et cetera maison
trouvait ça tellement sensible comme
sujet tellement délicat par rapport à
l'opinion allemande par exemple la
frontière Roderna des choses comme ça
qu'il a jamais fait le grand discours
explicatif
donc ça ça a manqué jusqu'à ce que des
historiens sérieux comme Bzo en France
Tilo Shaber en Allemagne reprennent
toutes les archives écrivent des choses
totalement positives là-dessus très
différentes des commentaires de l'époque
et j'ai j'ai un contreexemple, c'est
l'affaire de la guerre du golf quand
Saddam Husin met la main sur le cowet et
qu'il est question d'une action, les
tris/4 des Français sont contre toute
participation française à quoi que ce
soit.
Ça c'est 91, c'est ça ? 91.
Et oui, c'est d'ailleurs à peu près la
même époque que le début de la guerre
civile euh au Rwanda que le la menace de
de guerre civile. Donc
j'ai vu aussi
en 94
au début c'est l'action française qui
termine à Roucha 93 alors et où il y a
donc il y a pas assez d'explication ça
je le regrette vraiment vraiment. Alors
dans la fier du Covette, c'est tout à
fait l'inverse comme Miton pense qu'on
ne peut pas laisser peut pas laisser un
pays envahir et absorber un autre membre
des Nations Unies. Même raisonnement sur
le Wanda, il y a Ouanda tout ça. Mais
donc pour lui, c'est fondamental même si
les Français sont contre, lui il pense
qu'il faut être prêt à y aller le cas
échéant.
Donc il envoie des émissaires pendant
des mois pour dire à Saddam Hussein, il
faut que vous sortiez du couette, sinon
on va vraiment il aura la guerre. Et
l'autre le croit pas, il est tellement
borné et il connaît rien, il comprend
rien au monde. Bon, il comprend pas. Et
donc Mitan, on voit que c'est délicat.
il veut pas être désavoué par les
Français le moment venu et donc il fait
4 5 6 entretien conférence de presse
magnifique.
Il y a toutes les pédagogies
d'accompagnement
et tout le monde comprend que c'est très
embêtant d'avoir à participer à cette
guerre mais peut-être qu'on a pas le
choix et que le moment venu faut
peut-être y aller. Faut peut-être y
aller. Et finalement en janvier de
l'année suivante,
janvier de la suivante les trois/4 des
Français sont pour donc c'est ça qui a
manqué sur Rwanda sur sur Allemagne.
Mais j'ai pas complètement terminé de
répondre à votre question de tout à
l'heure sur la France. Je je dirais je
sais pas si on a terminé là mais
non on a tout le temps
on a tout le temps devant nous. Oui, on
alors je voudrais quand même ajouter
je voudrais ajouter que la France garde
plus de moyens que ce que les Français
croient.
On
n'est pas en short.
Vous connaissez le l'organisme PiW
américain qui fait des sondages
mondiaux. Certaines années, les Français
sont plus inquiets, plus pessimistes sur
l'avenir de la France que les Irakiens
sur l'avenir de l'Irak ou les Afghans
sur l'avenir de l'Afghanistan. Donc il y
a un bug quelque part et c'est un peu
relié à la nostalgie de la grande
puissance. Voyez,
c'est pas un bug, c'est parce que les
iraquins n'ont rien à perdre. D'accord,
ils ont déjà tout perdu.
Alors oubliez les irins, il y a quand
même une anomalie.
Il y a une anomalie quand même. Et donc
je pense que c'est cette nostalgie
un peu blessée quoi sur la la France qui
a été la grande puissance. On sait pas
trop quand d'ailleurs. En plus, les
bilans de France grande puissance sont
pas terribles, hein. Les bilan de Louis
XIV et de Napoléon, ça se discute quand
même. Donc c'est l'ancien donc moi je
plaide pour que les Français retrouvent
une certaine confiance en eux et là le
monde médiatique a un rôle à jouer quand
même.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du monde
médiatique ? D'ailleurs,
écoutez, j'ai j'ai beaucoup de sympathie
et d'estime pour les journalistes.
D'ailleurs, quand j'étais jeune, je
voulais devenir comme Jean la Couture
qui était un ami de mes parents, devenir
un reporter et cetera. Puis je suis
entré à l'ENA, ça a tourné autrement.
Mais mais je trouve le système dingue
globalement et c'est quand même très
difficile de faire un travail sérieux
là-dedans. Et puis disons l'information
continue, il y a des tas de gens très
bien là-dedans, mais ça comme
globalement le système hystérise les
médias d'au-dessus et le numérique
pardon les réseaux sociaux tirent vers
le bas. Je pense que c'est très
compliqué aujourd'hui de faire le job
bien quoi, d'essayer de dire des choses
sensées, d'avoir alors vous êtes un cas
complètement atypique, exceptionnel. Il
y a une durée presque illimitée alors
qu'en général les choses durent 5 6
minutes. On dit vous allez on vous
invite, on fait un entretien de très
longue durée, très approfondi de 18
minutes avec trois directs, je sais pas
où et cetera. Bon, c'est terrible. Moi,
j'ai plein d'amis dans ce mondel, ils en
souffrent tous.
Ils sont dedans, ils ont une vie
intéressante mais il ess toujours de
rebondir sur autre chose en fait. Donc
il y a il y a un problème du système
qu'il faudrait contrebalancer qui bon
c'est très bien que vous existiez hein.
Merci. Est-ce que c'est notre dernière
question ? C'est pas une question c'est
est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes génération ? Quelque chose
d'impérissable
qui va rester sur les réseaux ?
Non, je vais décevoir les réseaux parce
que les jeunes j'ai jamais beaucoup cru.
génération. En fait, moi quand j'avais
quand j'étais au lycée à 15 ans,
j'adorais passer mon temps avec des gens
plus âgés, voir très âgé qui me
raconaient des trucs qui me racontéis
les gens qui avaient eu des vies
extraordinaires ou atypiques et je
trouvais la plupart des gens de mon âge
sans intérêt en fait pas tous, j'ai
quelques amis que j'ai toujours
mais je crois pas tellement en
génération. Donc, il faudrait préciser
alors des jeunes français de tel et tel
âge, de telle catégorie et cetera.
[Musique]
Si alors et puis évidemment si on parla
à un jeune chinois, c'est pas la même
chose que si on parle un jeune rwandais
ou un jeune brésilien ou un jeune
polonais. C'est pas du tout pareil en
fait. Mais alors si on revient à la
France, je trouve que la charge
d'inquiétude qu'on leur met sur le dos
est trop lourde.
À force d'être conscient, au courant des
choses et cetera, des gens qui passent
leur vie sur les écrans d'avoir ça leur
ça leur ramodit le cerveau. Enfin bon,
je pense que pour un jeune aujourd'hui,
ça doit être terrifiant ce qu'il entend
sur l'état du monde, sur le l'écologie
pas du tout présentée comme je l'ai fait
avec un processus scientifique, mais
c'est de effrayant en fait. Donc, je
voudrais dire quelque chose qui est euh
n'ayez pas peur. N'ayez pas peur. Mais
Jean-Paul II l'a déjà dit, c'est ça le
problème. N'ayez pas peur. Ayez
confiance en vous. Mais on va pas leur
dire qu'ils vont bâtir ensemble un monde
meilleur que leurs parents, qui sont
méchants, bla bla bla parce que dans
chaque génération, il y a la la même
proportion d'imbécile, je pense, et puis
la même proportion de gens qui défendent
des idées intéressantes ou des idées
absurdes. Donc, ils vont se battre à
l'intérieur de leur génération. Mais
l'idée générale, c'est qu'il faut pas
être terrorisé à ce point.
retrouver le goût du du progrès. Le
progrès a été effrayant, complètement
dérapé dans beaucoup de domaines. Il
faut quand même retrouver l'idée, pas
forcément les activités prédatrices,
mais l'idée confiance en soi, idée,
curiosité,
sens de l'avenir.
Mais je sais pas à quoi ça sert de
vous savez des jeunes
dans votre question, les jeunes
générations, ils ont quel âge ?
très jeune.
Ils ont leur monde à
peut-être que vous y arrivez vous
subptissement mais je suis pas sûr.
On essaye Hubert Vedrine
essayer. C'est bien.
Bravo en tout cas pour une chose.
Non mais est central c'est d'avoir créé
cet espace de durée. Ça c'est formidable
ça.
Hubert Vedrine merci.
[Musique]